Ich habe noch gar nichts wirklich gespielt auf der neuen Kiste.
Ich habe gestern den Stream ausgemacht und das war's. Mehr habe ich danach nicht mehr mitgemacht.
Die liegt immer noch hier neben mir. Ich muss mir auch mal angucken, dass das die
zweite Platte richtig erkennt. Oder, wisst ihr was ich mir auch überlegt habe,
was man machen könnte? Man könnte einfach Doubleboot machen mit einem Windows und
Steam drauf, falls man doch mal was spielen will, was Windows Only ist.
Oder vielleicht irgendwelche neuen Emulator-Dinger braucht die die es nur unter Windows gibt oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Weil für meine Games, da reichen 500G mal sowas von locker aus.
Ich will ja dann nicht mal großartig Xbox, obwohl man es spielen könnte theoretisch.
Ich glaube, das erste Gears of War läuft auf dem Xbox Emulator halbwegs.
Also die Games sind ja alle nicht groß. Ich meine, so ein N64-Game ist keine Ahnung.
Wo sind denn die? 20 MB? Das ist ja nichts.
Und selbst ein PS1-Game ist maximal irgendwie 650-700 MB, je nachdem was sie für eine CD verwenden.
Also da kriegst du einiges unter.
Raspberry Pi, das reicht ganz knapp für ein N64 und auch nicht alles.
Der Raspberry Pi ist tatsächlich keine gute Base dafür.
Also wenn dir reicht NES und SNES und 16-Bit-Konsolen, dann ist okay.
Alles andere hat also seine Probleme mit. Und Upscaling ist schon mal gar nicht.
Also bei 16-Bit-Konsolen kannst du Upscalen, aber bei 16-Bit-Konsolen bringt Upscalen in der Regel nicht.
Also das lohnt sich nicht. Dann hol dir lieber irgendeine günstige X86-Emulator-Kiste.
Also X86-Based-Emulator-Kiste. Auch was billiges.
Also es ist schneller als ein Raspberry Pi und besser.
Also Raspberry Pi 4 schafft mit Ach und Krach ein N64.
Da sieht man mal wie viel Leistungsfähiger als ein Raspberry Pi die kleine Kiste hier ist.
Mein Gut, die kostet auch mindestens 550 Euro.
Gut, ein Raspberry Pi. Das kostet nicht aktuell einen Raspberry Pi, wenn du einen kriegst.
Ein 4-8G RAM. Wahrscheinlich auch 80-90 Euro, was überhaupt nicht wert ist.
Wenn das Ding den Originalpreis kostet, wäre das voll und ganz okay.
Aber zu den aktuellen Preisen lohnt sich der Raspberry Pi einfach null.
Dann fährst du mit einem Mini-PC oder irgendwelchen Low-Power-Intel-Kisten tatsächlich besser.
Das lohnt sich aktuell gar nicht.
Das Einzige, wofür es sich lohnt, wenn du irgendein spezielles Header-Modul hast,
das nur auf den Raspberry Pi passt und wenn es dafür dann nur die Software gibt
und dafür nur Tutorials gibt und so. Vielleicht.
Aber das meiste gibt es ja für alles.
Es macht ja keiner Software. Meistens das.
Explizit für den Raspberry Pi.
Es ist ganz viel. Ganz viel Pisan-Zeug.
Es läuft potenziell eigentlich überall drauf.
Aber klar, es gibt spezielle Header-Boards, die nur auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Oder spezielle Cases zum Beispiel, um auf die Hut-Schienen zu machen.
Manchmal ist es sicherlich sinnvoll, den Raspberry Pi zu nehmen.
Da muss dann aber auch kein Vierer sein. Meistens.
Aber preislich lohnt sich das aktuell überhaupt gar nicht.
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Barry-Base.
Nee, nicht Barry. Barry.
Haben die überhaupt welche?
Alter, ich sollte mal einen Dark Reader.
Die haben überhaupt keine mehr, oder?
Derzeit nicht lieferbar, nicht lieferbar, nicht lieferbar, nicht lieferbar.
Sag mal, der nächste Raspberry Pi, der lieferbar sein wird, ist der Raspberry Pi 5, oder?
Guck mal, das lohnt sich.
Alter, das ist doch nicht mehr normal.
170, hohe...
Alles klar.
Also ganz ehrlich, den Raspberry Pi kannst du komplett vergessen, einfach komplett.
Ich bin froh, dass ich für Bastelzwerke noch zwei Raspberry Pi 4s hier habe.
Die werde ich auch nicht für irgendwas verwenden.
Die bleiben fürs Basteln erhalten, bis es mal wieder was gibt.
Weil dafür sind die wirklich gut.
Die sind auch beide in so einem schönen Clear Case.
Oh, knapp.
Beinahe hätte ich...
Dass jetzt auch noch dieser schließende Kack, dieser schließende Button da oben ist, Alter.
Mag Windows 11 echt nicht.
Ja, die sind auch beide in so einem schönen Flirrk, Flirrk Case.
Passiv gekühlt.
Also, lohnt sich überhaupt gar nicht, was Raspberry Pi ist aktuell.
Da würde ich tatsächlich eher auf irgendwas anderes gucken.
Es gibt ja andere Single Board Computer und, ganz im Ernst, ich würde mir Intel Intel
based Low Power oder AMD based Low Power Hardware angucken.
Du kannst, du kannst für diese Sachen easy, easy was, was selbst bauen, aber meistens
nicht gescheit in dem Formfaktor.
Das beste, was du selbst bauen kannst, ist so, ist irgendwie so eine Mikro, Mikro ATX Mini.
Die sind ja auch relativ klein, aber nicht ganz so klein.
Gebrauchte Thin Clients funktionieren, wenn man so Emulationstäusch machen will, auch
wunderbar.
Halt auch nicht wirklich, also die schaffen zwar n64, aber danach hört es meistens auf.
Also je nachdem, was man, was man machen will, muss man, muss man gucken.
Aber viele Thin Clients sind tatsächlich eine ganz gute Alternative für Raspberry Pi und
brauchen auch gar nicht so viel mehr Strom.
Wo es natürlich aufhört ist, wenn du GPIO Inputs brauchst, das ist ja eigentlich das,
was den Raspberry Pi ursprünglich mal so interessant gemacht hat, dass du, was weiß
ich, wie viel hatten der, 30 oder 20 oder 20 GPIO Pins oder 24, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie viele GPIO Pins.
40, 40, 40 GPIO Pins, also dafür ist der Raspberry Pi natürlich so ungeschlagen, was
das angeht, weil das hast du auf normaler Hardware halt nicht, schon auf irgendeinem
Thin Client oder Mini PC hast du das halt nicht.
Du könntest halt höchstens mit einem ESP32 dran, aber da hast du halt kein vollwertiges
Linux und keinen vollwertigen Rechner.
Also das hat durchaus Sinn, hat durchaus Sinn, aber aktuelle Preise von Raspberry Pi sind
einfach so komplett jenseits von Gut und Böse, das kannst du dir eigentlich nicht
sinnvoll erklären, sich das zu kaufen.
Sind das die Atom-Dinger gewesen, N5000, die Atom-Teile waren, die Atom-Dinger wurden
ja mittlerweile unbenannt in Celeron sogar, also Celerons gibt es jetzt, bei Intel blickst
du eh nicht mehr durch.
Also manches, was früher Atom war, heißt jetzt Celeron, zum Beispiel diese Dinger,
das waren für Atom-CPUs und jetzt sind es Celeron, was auch, da blickt wirklich nur
noch, wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Intel blickt dadurch, die J-Dinger die sind ganz
gut, da hatte ich selbst zwei Jahre eins im Einsatz, hier so eine Low-Power-Kiste, da
hatte ich ein Board mit PCIe Express drauf und hatte eine 10G-Karte drin und das ging
ganz gut, ich meine das ging jetzt nicht bis tatsächlich da wirklich 10 Gigabit, aber
600, 600, 700 MB hat man trotzdem durchgekriegt übers Netzwerk.
Wohlgemerkt mit einem Quad-Core und dann auch mit Festplatten-Verschlüsselung.
Was für eine Kiste, sowas hier, sowas hatte ich ja selbst eine Weile im Einsatz, allerdings
mit einem, mit weniger SATA-Ports und dafür einen vollen Slot, allerdings war der auch
bloß XX, also zweifach, zweifach angebunden und es ist auch nur PCIe Express 2, muss man
ein bisschen gucken, mal gucken wie die, was zum Teufel ist eigentlich los mit der S-Rock
Seite, was hatten die S-Rock Seite für Probleme, aber was Neues haben die nicht wie es aussieht,
ok, die Mini-Lake Refresh, Apollo Lake sind noch die älteren, ja und da sind nur PCIe
Express 2, nicht so, nicht so der Wahnsinn und da habe ich irgendwas verpasst die Woche
Leute, lass mal GitHub Trends schnell gucken, Moment, mal gucken ob ich irgendwelche Issues
übersehen habe, ne hab ich nicht, ich müsste vielleicht mal ein paar Sachen fixen, ich
hab schon erst nicht nach drei Monaten her wo ich das zuletzt geupdatet hab, Explore Trends
zeig her, What's popular on GitHub Trending, lass mal her, Trended diese Woche, also was
gibt's hier wieder, Instruct Picks to Picks, ich hab seriously keine Ahnung was das sein
soll, ahja, No Description, ah Machine Learning, was sonst, was sonst, Nuxt, ah Vue.js, ja
das kenn ich, eine Vim-Config, ok, noch mal Machine Learning, Machine Learning, Krypto,
Machine Learning, AI Kram, also wenn man sich aktuell nicht für Krypto Kram und AI Kram
interessiert großartig ist GitHub gerade, GitHub Trends die letzten paar Monate jetzt
nicht so spannend, guck mal es ist alles voll, nur besteht nur aus AI Zeug, ich mein es ist
verständlich, aber es wäre trotzdem ganz gut wenn man ein bisschen wieder was anderes
renten würde, zwischendurch mal, Machine Learning, Machine Learning, Machine Learning, oh war
eine Sache und das Windows Terminal, naja geil, ok, können wir gleich sein lassen, Jack
MK, nee, kenne ich mich nicht aus, ich hab Jack MK mal installiert im Docker Container
laufen lassen ein bisschen rumzuklicken um mir das anzugucken aber noch nie wirklich
betrieben, keine Ahnung von, ich hab bei mir lokalen Zappix, ist auch nicht der Weiße
als letzter Schluss ehrlich gesagt, die Config vom Zappix ist halt richtig abwackt, schade
dass es irgendwie keine ordentlich bedienbare Monitoring Lösung gibt, so eine Mischung
aus Prometheus Exporter, Grafana und sonst was, das ist halt auch mehr wir bauen uns
ein Monitoring System selbst als was fertiges, außerdem ist es eher für Metriken und weniger
für Hostess ab und down, auch wenn es auch geht aber schön ist es nicht, ich hab keine
Ahnung ob das Amazon Stuff war, warum Nagios nicht mehr im Trend ist wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich
wegen der Config, ich persönlich mag Nagios, ich würde jetzt heute vielleicht keine neue
Nagios Installation mehr machen aber an sich mochte ich Nagios immer.
Echt, dann ist es ja gut, ich hab immer gedacht die Leute pennen dadurch nochmal extra ein,
weil ich bin am Sonntag morgens meistens nicht, sondern ich bin.
Jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich ohne Scheiß, jetzt habe ich mir zwei Reviews angeguckt
zu Mini-PCs und jetzt ist YouTube der Meinung, guck Mini-PC Videos, guck Mini-PC Videos,
ok 2023 Top CLI Tools you need to know, ok wir skippen das jetzt ein bisschen, also Top
CLI Tools you need to know, ok AM, AM ist ein Poggers CLI Tool, ah hier sieht man es
schon ok, ok das ist, das fällt bei mir raus mit dem neuen Terminal, brauch ich nicht mehr,
Just Forehead, das kenne ich, das ist irgendwas in Go programmiertes um glaub automatisch
Envalment Variablen pro Verzeichnis zu setzen oder sowas, brauch man nicht, das kenne ich
nicht, was ist das, Configuration Management braucht man auch nicht, also für das Dot-File
für eine lokale Kiste, brauch man nicht, ok wir wissen, dass wir das Video nicht angucken
müssen, ja meint ich ja, meint ich ja, gibt's ja nicht, ich mein Zabbix ist tatsächlich,
CheckMK wahrscheinlich auch, da habe ich aber nicht so viel Plan von, Zabbix ist eine relativ
gute All in One Lösung, spätestens seit die auch Prometheus Exporter konsumieren können,
das dumme an Zabbix ist, dass die Zabbix Config einfach eklig ist, über Swap Interface, also
das ist wirklich maximal, maximal verwirrend, aufgebaut und benannt auch alles, tschüss
ich danke für den Zabb, Pogu, ja ansonsten, war die Woche irgendwas spannendes, irgendwas
verpasst, gab es, es gab doch irgendwelche Daten Leaks wieder, Paypal, hatte Paypal nicht
in den Daten liegt letztens, ich erinnere mich an News dazu, Telekom USA,
ne glaub die Woche, glaub die Woche war nix, hatte, Heise hatte doch so irgendeinen Wochenüberblick,
den finde ich aber nicht, Wochenrückblick, Replay, genau, ja aber nicht von 2018, irgendwas
aktuelles, Alter da blickst du wieder nicht durch, 27.01, nop, ach keine Ahnung, da,
YouTube hat auch nix spannendes, Ultra Cheap 300 Dollar Hackintosh Build, juckt mich überhaupt
nicht, Alexi Bexy ist das letzte was ich mir jetzt angucke, Ftested 5000 Gadgets, das ist
wahrscheinlich auch total uninteressant, aber mal gucken, könnte zumindest irgendwas halbwegs
spannendes sein, was verdient ein Kfz Meister, wenn ihm der Laden gehört wahrscheinlich
ganz gut, ok Leute was ist hier los, aber heute ist es 5 Jahre alt, watch this Russian
Hacker break into your computer in minutes, ok, ok, ok, Moment, Moment, das ist bestimmt
ein Paintschamp das Video, Alter, so Videos sind immer extrem Paintschamp, ok, also wir
gucken jetzt dem russischen Hacker zu wie er in unser Computer einbricht, guckt ihr das
Ding mit Hydro Hype, Moment, Hydro Hype, war das nicht vor 3 Jahren oder so, so ging
es nach Hydro Hype weiter, ok, aha, ok, ok, wir müssen jetzt gucken wie uns der russische
Hacker in Minuten hackt, oh diese Beiträge sind immer so cringe, Alter, ok auf, ja super,
faken Wireless Point, super gehackt Schabba, nur, nur echt Erkermens können das, ok, ok,
ok, ok, hier honey.
Ich versuche dich zu überzeugen, dass du ein Update machen musst, weißt du, deine Maschine...
Oh man! Alter!
Leute, alles klar!
In Minuten!
Hahaha!
Genau! Guck mal hier!
Basically, um in Minuten zu werden hackt,
musst du einfach Dinge tun, die dir nie...
Du würdest nie total Sinn machen!
Hahaha!
Das dachte ich mir auch gerade!
Oh man!
Diese Videos, das merkst du schon!
Das merkst du schon, wie das anfängt!
Alter!
Schreit nicht so rum!
Also manche...
Mehr Klick-Beld, please!
Ja, vor allem hätte ihr VPN und sowas da...
Wahrscheinlich sogar was gebracht!
Also wenn die Verbindung funktioniert hätte...
Hydro!
Zeig mal, ich kann mich anders...
Was war das denn nochmal?
War das...
Warte mal, lass mal, das war kein Energy Drink, ne?
War das die Creme?
Ich versuche mich gerade wieder dran zu erinnern...
Was das war?
Das war irgendeine Creme,
die ja irgendwelchen
Instagram-Influenzern verkaufen wollte, oder?
Die Creme, die Kleidgel war.
Genau! Und wo er denen erzählt hat,
was die sagen sollen.
Und das...
Wenn ich mich richtig dran erinnern kann,
das Verwerfliche da dran war nochmal was?
Dass die alle so getan haben, als war es nicht gesponsort?
Oder was war nochmal das Verwerfliche?
Ich kann mich nur noch ganz dunkel dran erinnern,
dass sie das nicht klar als Sponsoring kennzeichnet haben,
so nach dem Motto,
ich habe das zufälligerweise gefunden
und finde das ganz toll.
Oder was war nochmal das Problem da dran?
Ich meine, irgendwelche Produktplacements sind jetzt
wenig skandalös 2023.
Okay, dass sie nicht gesponsort werden.
Okay, zeig mal her. 12 Minuten können wir uns mal geben.
Herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem Zweitkanal,
endlich wieder mit einem brandneuen Video.
Heute geht es um das legendäre Thema Hydrohype.
Ich glaube, das ist das Projekt,
für das mich die meisten kennen.
Ich sage mal so, es ist Flug und Segen zugleich.
Weil auf der einen Seite habe ich mit Hydrohype
die Messlatte für mich selber unfassbar hochgesetzt.
Das merke ich an zwei, drei Stellen.
Und zwar die erste ist, dass ich selber mit meinen Videos
und den Projekten, die ich anfange,
mega unzufrieden bin, weil ich halt immer wieder
mich verbessern möchte, immer noch krasser werden möchte
als bei Hydrohype.
Und das kann einem einfach auf lange Sicht gar nicht gelingen.
Und das zweite ist einfach auch die Außenwahrnehmung.
Die Leute, die mich für Hydrohype kennen, erwarten,
dass ich am besten jede Woche so ein Projekt auf die Beine stelle.
Und das ist leider nicht möglich.
Aber bevor ich hier noch in Tränen ausbreche,
möchte ich natürlich auch nochmal das ganze Thema Hydrohype
Revue passieren lassen.
Genau, erklär für Noobs wie mich nochmal,
um was es eigentlich ging.
Ich habe schon wieder die Hälfte vergessen.
Stimmt, das war das mit Kleidgel.
Genau, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Inhaltsstoffe drucken lassen, aber auch erfundene Sachen
wie Uran, Pipikaka, Seat Oil und Asbestos.
Stimmt, jetzt kann ich mich wieder erinnern.
Einfach, weil ich Influencer testen wollte.
Und da kommen wir auch schon zur ersten Frage,
die mir immer wieder gestellt wird.
Wie kamst du damals auf die Idee?
Und es ist eigentlich ganz banal.
Ich bin selbst einfach großer YouTube- und Instagram-Sucht,
die mittlerweile auch TikTok natürlich.
Und sehe einfach, dass dort immer mehr Werbung läuft.
Werbung, und das ist auch wichtig zu betonen,
ist nicht schlecht.
Werbung ist erstmal neutral.
Nur, wer sich für die Werbung hingibt
und wie die Werbung konzipiert wird,
da scheidet sich tatsächlich die Spreu vom Weizen.
Denn da muss man drauf achten.
Neutral kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Aber er hat schon recht.
Es kommt drauf an, wie es verkauft wird.
Und vor allem, ob es gekennzeichnet ist als Werbung.
Nick, danke schön für den Zap.
Ich finde das alles okay, solange es erkennbar ist,
dass es Werbung ist.
Es ist zwar teilweise etwas merkwürdig,
wenn man dann...
Ja, irgendwelche Paarungen sieht, die nicht so passen.
Irgendwelche Security-Channels, die NordVPN anpreisen.
Aber letztlich ist es kein Ding, weil mache ich es selbst.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als war ich super scharf drauf.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen,
wie dieses komische Mobile-Game hieß,
wo ich mal 60 Sekunden was...
Wie hieß denn das?
Dieser komische Peggle-Klon da.
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Nicht Coilmaster.
Nein, Ray-Channel-Legends war es auch nicht.
Wie hieß das denn?
Ich habe es komplett verdrängt schon wieder.
Matchmaster, genau, ja.
Matchmaster.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich super scharf drauf gewesen wäre,
ein Matchmaster-Sponsoring zu machen.
Aber die haben ganz ordentlich bezahlt.
Sonst mache ich die Sachen ja prinzipiell nicht.
Das ist mir auch zu schade.
Ich will die Videos nicht mit Werbung vollkleistern.
Ja, Match...
Es ist nicht so, dass ich da scharf drauf gewesen bin.
Ich würde das normalerweise nie spielen.
Aber ich meine, man hat das in den 60 Sekunden
halt mal ein bisschen angepriesen.
Und ich glaube, niemand,
der mich wirklich guckt,
war der Meinung, ich bin voll überzeugt,
ich spiele jeden Tag Matchmasters.
Aber gut, es ist als Werbung gekennzeichnet.
Das ist für mich das Wichtige.
Also wenn ich ein Video sehe,
wo einer irgendwas anpreist und ich sehe,
dass das Werbung ist, ist mir das vollkommen recht.
Was ich fragwürdig finde
und was sicherlich rechtlich auch problematisch ist,
wenn du Werbung quasi als
so persönliches,
persönliches verkaufst.
Und nach dem Motto nicht, es ist Werbung
und man sieht, dass es Werbung ist,
sondern ich habe zufällig diese tolle Uhr
heute im Aldi gefunden.
Das ist die schönste Uhr, die ich je gesehen habe.
Und du weißt halt nicht, dass das eine gesponserte,
gesponsertes Urenplacement ist.
Dass man einfach das Ganze kritisch hinterfragt
und guckt, wofür kann ich denn
mit meinem Gesicht stehen
und nicht einfach zu gucken,
gibt es dafür?
Ja, eins muss ich jetzt an der Stelle nochmal sagen.
Ich habe das früher auch deutlich kritischer gesehen.
Also zu Zeiten, wo ich auf YouTube angefangen habe,
war es ja fast noch verpönt,
YouTube Partner zu werden.
Vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch dran.
Also wer Partner wurde, war geldgeil und sowas.
Damals konnte noch keiner sich
wirklich darüber Gedanken machen,
mal als, das Wort Influencer gab es damals noch gar nicht,
Content Creator, dass man damit,
wir reden ja noch nicht mal von reich werden,
sondern man könnte davon eigentlich,
man könnte quasi professioneller
Content Creator auf YouTube werden,
wenn man verdient sein Lebensunterhalt.
Das haben sich die meisten damals nicht
wirklich vorstellen können.
Und dementsprechend hat man das natürlich
alles auch ein bisschen kritischer gesehen.
Mittlerweile denke ich mir halt, ja,
die Leute müssen halt gucken,
gerade die, die das hauptberuflich machen,
die müssen halt gucken, wie sie hinkommen.
Und manchmal musst du da wahrscheinlich
auch ein paar Sponsorings machen,
die du persönlich nicht so geil findest,
weil du hast die Auswahl, entweder
du kommst gut über die Runden oder nicht.
Und wenn du nicht über die Runden kommst,
machst du vielleicht mal das eine oder andere Play,
wo du jetzt normalerweise denkst,
so geil ist das aber nicht, aber was willst du machen?
Du bist ja komplett auf Gedei und Verderben
von diesem ganzen Ökosystem abhängig
als Vollzeit Content Creator.
Das heißt, du musst auch deine Streaming-Zeiten machen,
du musst auch deine Content-Produktion einhalten,
ob du Bock hast oder nicht,
ob dich gerade alles abfuckt oder nicht.
Das ist egal.
Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen,
dass sich das viele Leute zu idealisiert vorstellen,
so nach dem Motto, ich bin jetzt ein 12-Jähriger
in der Schule, guckt mir gerne Streams an,
würde gern selbst Streamer werden
und kann mir eigentlich nichts Besseres vorstellen
wie den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen und streamen.
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob du vorm Rechner sitzt und streamst,
weil du gerade vorm Rechner sitzen willst und streamst,
oder ob du jetzt vorm Rechner sitzt und streamst,
oder ob du jetzt vorm Rechner sitzt und jetzt streamen musst,
ob du willst oder nicht,
oder jetzt irgendwas aufnehmen musst,
die irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen musst.
Also, das ist schon ein Unterschied
und auf Dauer ist das belastender,
als ich viele vorstellen könnte.
Bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Ich bin halt in der komfortablen Situation,
ich bin halt in der komfortablen Situation,
dass ein noch das andere wirklich machen müsste,
aber ich merke es auch schon teilweise.
Ich habe jetzt 12 Tage kein Video mehr gemacht auf YouTube,
ich habe eine große Themenliste,
also ich könnte jetzt was aufnehmen,
aber irgendwie habe ich gerade nicht so wirklich Bock,
jetzt mich hinzusetzen.
Und ich merke es jetzt aber auch,
ich müsste jetzt eigentlich mal,
und bei mir ist es nur ein reines,
wie soll ich sagen so,
allein schon, dass die Leute wieder ein Video bekommen
und bei anderen ist es so,
ich müsste mal, dass ich jetzt übertrieben gesagt,
dass ich mir was zu essen kaufen kann.
Also, es ist schon ein Unterschied,
wie abhängig man als Vollzeit-Content-Creator davon ist.
Aber muss man dafür seine Follower belügen?
Naja, wenn du es als Werbung kennzeichnest,
machst du das ja nicht.
Also, wenn da steht,
diese 60 Sekunden ist Werbung,
dann ist es eher eine prinzipielle Frage,
wie ist der Inhalt der Werbung?
Weil, guckt in Fernsehen,
da stand dann auch früher Michael Schumacher
und hat Werbung gemacht,
oder es stehen irgendwelche anderen Sport-Profis da,
die dir erzählen,
oh, ich benutze jetzt Alpecin in meinem Haar
und alles ist ganz geil.
Also, das ist ja auch nichts anderes.
Aber es ist halt wichtig,
dass es als Werbung zu erkennen ist.
Das ist gar nicht so extrem,
wie es immer getan wird.
Ich hatte schon immer Phasen,
wo ich wochenlang, teilweise monatelang nichts gemacht habe
und dann ein Video hochgeladen habe.
Wenn es ein gutes Thema ist,
was die Leute interessiert, klappt das.
Also, YouTube hat das mittlerweile im Griff.
Das ist ein bisschen ein Motivationskiller,
wenn du längere Zeit nichts gemacht hast.
Also, längere Zeit reden wir hier von 3-4 Monaten plus.
Also, wenn du mal so ein Quartal
oder so nichts hochgeladen hast,
dann hast du das Problem,
ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt,
ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, woran es liegt,
aber es ist so, weil ich das jetzt schon gemerkt habe,
dass YouTube deinen Kanal erstmal
in so einen Schlaf- oder Inaktiv-Modus setzt,
was bedeutet,
dass auch deine Analytics
und deine Counter und so,
alles nur noch sehr unregelmäßig
aktualisiert wird und geupdatet wird
und auch Leute, die ihr
Account geschlossen haben,
werden nicht richtig von den Abonnenten abgezogen und sowas.
So und das erste, was passiert ist,
wenn du mal so 3-4 Monate inaktiv warst,
du lädst was hoch
und selbst wenn es ein richtig gutes Video ist,
du kriegst innerhalb der ersten 24 Stunden erstmal
50-200 Unsubs.
Einfach so.
Das liegt glaube ich mal gar nicht daran,
weil alle Leute unsubben.
Warum sollen die auf einmal unsubben?
Weil die haben ja für den gleichen Content vor auch gesubbt
und machen es ja normalerweise auch nicht,
sondern weil YouTube erstmal anfängt,
irgendwelche Sachen nachzufahren
jetzt auf deinem Account,
wenn du wieder aktiv wirst.
Zum Beispiel wird dann YouTube erstmal checken,
manche haben ihren Account geschlossen,
wir aktualisieren das jetzt mal.
Das machen die erstmal immer
regelmäßig bei Video Uploads
und das ist halt sehr unmotivierend,
wenn man gerade wieder anfängt nach 3-4 Monaten
und eine gute Idee hat, was hoch lädt
und erstmal instant 200 De-Abos kriegt
in den ersten 2 Stunden.
Wo du denkst so, hä?
Aber das ist irgendwie YouTube-Geschichte,
ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Ansonsten hat YouTube eigentlich
ganz gut den Griff, aber trotzdem,
ich müsste tatsächlich mal wieder was hochladen.
Es gibt auch, wie gesagt,
ich hab auch eine richtig lange Themenliste,
ich wollte ja zu diesem Emulations-
Emulations-Ding was machen,
aber ich glaube,
da nehme ich selbst nochmal was auf,
bisschen strukturierter,
weil das ist ein Thema, wo ich denke,
das interessiert viele.
Ok, wir gucken uns erstmal das Video
fertig an.
Influencer-Werbung.
...gesagt haben möchte, da ist halt das,
wie sagt man, das Zündlein an der Waage,
ist glaube ich das richtige Stichwort.
Und deswegen wollte ich ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen,
wo man wirklich sagen kann,
ey, ihr habt nur aufs Geld geschaut.
Und das war bei Hydride so, denn hier drin war keine
Anti-Aging-Creme, so wie angepriesen,
sondern einfach nur... Aber mit diesem Holzdeckel sieht
es auch schon so schön öko aus, das passt irgendwie
aktuell. Das heißt, die Influencerinnen und
Influencer, die ich damit reinlegen wollte,
haben sich im Zweifel Gleitgel ins Gesicht geschmiert.
Das war damals dann Inissa Wukwitsch,
die Freundin von Simon Desue, wo ich jetzt
übrigens... Wait a minute.
Gibt's den überhaupt noch? Die sind die nicht
alle nach Dubai ausgewandert?
Oder nach Katar? Oder nach... frag mich nicht.
Und...
Sind die da eigentlich noch? Oder sind die alle wieder da?
Ich muss mal...
Wir gucken uns kein Video an.
Keine Sorge.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man den Typ schreibt.
Gibt's den überhaupt
noch?
4,2 Millionen... Nee,
okay, vor zwei Jahren.
Den gibt's
anscheinend nicht mehr. Aber gut,
der hat genug Kohle gemacht.
...
um jetzt eine Inissa Bugwitsch oder eine Vanessa Mariposa, die später auch noch drauf reingefallen ist, dafür zu mobben, zu...
Warum nicht?
Ja, beleidigen oder sogar Morddrohungen auszusprechen...
Na gut, Morddrohung ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel.
Wollte ich natürlich nicht. Ich finde, dass Kritik auch bei Social Media völlig gerechtfertigt ist und dass man sachlich in den Kommentaren kritisieren kann.
Aber alles darüber hinaus sollte auf jeden Fall nicht sein.
Vanessa Mariposa ist das nächste Stichwort...
Wer sich ein bisschen drüber lustig machen kann man doch.
Bei Morddrohungen ist natürlich was ganz anderes, ein bisschen drüber lustig machen.
Ich mein, warum nicht?
Hätte die darauf reingefallen ist und sogar sich noch eine schöne Geschichte überlegt hatte, wo sie denn diese Creme angeblich im Biomarkt entdeckt haben.
Nämlich bei ihrer Mama in Salzburg.
Da wollte ich euch noch ein Produkt zeigen, was ich letztens bei meiner Mama...
Alter, wenn ich die Instagram Influencer alle schon sehe.
Oh, meine Güte.
... in Salzburg entdeckt habe.
Wenn ihr diesen Satz genauso mit Gänsehaut sagen könnt wie ich, dann schreibt doch jetzt gerne mal lieben Gruß an die Mama aus Salzburg in die Kommentare.
Würde ich mich sehr sehr freuen.
Die beiden habe ich erstmal reingelegt mit Hydrohype.
Habe gezeigt, ey, sobald Geld im Spiel ist, sagen manche Influencer einfach nicht mehr die Wahrheit und versuchen euch zu veräppeln.
Dann kam ja noch der dritte Kandidat ins Spiel.
Ja gut, das ist in der Werbung eigentlich normal.
Sag mal, du darfst dir in der Werbung nicht wirklich...
Also dir darf jetzt keiner was anpreisen, was das Produkt nicht hat.
Also du kannst jetzt kein Auto mit zwei Türen verkaufen und sagen es hat vier Türen.
Du kannst das aber geschickt umschreiben.
Also was du sagen darfst, ich meine ich bin jetzt kein Anwalt, aber du kannst zum Beispiel ein super kleines Auto verkaufen und sagen geräumiger Innenraum und sowas.
Das ist so, was du nicht sagen darfst ist 100 Quadratmeter, aber das ist ja falsch.
Aber wenn du sagst geräumiger Innenraum, das ist so wie wenn es Wohnungen gibt, so Wohnungen in bester Lage und sowas.
Ja gut, bester Lage, so neben einer Kreuzung oder neben einer Bahnschiene oder sonst irgendwas.
Das ist natürlich sehr dehnbar, was das bedeuten kann.
Niemand geringer ist als Leon Machère.
Den wollte ich damals ja auch mit Hydrohype reinlegen und er hat dann den Spieß umgedreht.
Denn während meiner Produktion für Hydrohype hat sich der Spieß so ein bisschen gedreht.
Als ich nämlich gedacht habe, ich werde von einer Großfamilie, von der ich nie was gehört habe, nämlich El Eknu bedroht.
Ich habe das damals tatsächlich ernst genommen, weil es auch ernst rübergebracht wurde vom angeblichen Manager von Leon.
Und habe mich auch in Kreisen umgehört, ob man denn von dieser Familie was gehört hat. Niemand hat davon was gehört.
Und am Ende kam raus, Leon hat uns alle hops genommen und das kann ich heute genauso sagen.
Er hat uns mit dieser Aktion sehr, sehr hops genommen, nicht nur mich, sondern auch die Reaction-Szene.
Und da muss man wirklich sagen, Chapeau an der Stelle. Schade, dass er es noch mal irgendwie geschafft hat, so einen überkrassen Prank zu machen.
Weil da hat er wirklich mal gezeigt, was man auf die Beine stellen kann, wenn man sich darauf fokussiert, wenn man es ernst meint und keinen Fake-Prank macht.
Muss ich wirklich sagen, hat mir damals echt gut gefallen, auch wenn ich in diesem Fall das Opfer war.
Bei den anderen beiden sah die Rechtfertigung ganz, ganz unterschiedlich aus.
Bei Vanessa Mariposa war es dann so, dass sie gesagt hat, es tut ihr mega leid.
Oh nein, Entschuldigungsvideo. Das ist ja mittlerweile schon der Standard, oder?
Also ich glaube, es gibt keinen größeren Influencer, also Instagram und sowas in der Richtung,
die nicht schon irgendwelche heulenden Entschuldigungsvideos gemacht haben.
Das gehört doch eigentlich zum guten Ton mittlerweile.
Dass du dich vor die Kamera stellst, irgendwie erzählst, wie furchtbar leid dir das tut,
am besten noch anfängst oder wenn du nicht wirklich gerade heulen musst vor der Kamera zumindest so aussiehst, als hast du gerade geheult
und dann erstmal dich wahnsinnig für alles entschuldigt.
Aber diese Entschuldigungsvideos sind teilweise übelst geil.
Die Leute sitzen dann da und ihnen tut das alles so wahnsinnig leid und es ist alles so schrecklich und sonst was.
Aber zwischen den Zeilen sagen sie ihnen, also viele Entschuldigungsvideos sind so,
sagen sie, eigentlich ist ja gar nichts Schlimmes passiert und habe ich auch nichts verkehrt gemacht.
Aber es tut mir so leid und ich muss jetzt heulen.
Sie möchten das nie wieder so machen und sie bereut es und es war auf jeden Fall eine Notlüge und wird nicht mehr vorkommen.
Habe ich ihr auch ein Jahr lang geglaubt, bis dann mein nächstes Projekt A Whole kam und sie es wieder gemacht hat.
Wer das nicht gesehen hat, gern mal abchecken.
Und bei Inissa war es tatsächlich so, dass sie ein L-langes Statement verfasst hat,
wo sie gesagt hat, ey es gibt so viele Gründe, warum das so gelaufen ist.
Als erstes Marvin Wildhage hat darauf bestanden, dass ich mir das Zeug ins Gesicht schniere und dann noch ein Vorher-Nachhalt-Foto mache.
Ich habe das Vorher-Nachhalt-Foto nicht bearbeitet.
Ich habe nur das Licht anders gemacht, damit man irgendwie einen Unterschied sieht.
Naja, sie hätte auch einfach sagen können, wenn ihr das wirklich gar nicht zusagt, hätte sie auch einfach sagen können, ne mache ich nicht.
Das ist ja durch, aber du kennst die Bedingungen ja, wenn du es unterschreibst.
Die Auftraggeber, denen steht relativ frei, was sie in Auftrag geben, aber als Influencer steht es dir genauso frei,
entweder zu sagen, ich nehme es gar nicht an oder unter diesen Bedingungen, oder die sind diese Punkte.
Das habe ich persönlich auch schon gemacht, dass irgendwelche Anfragen gekommen sind,
da kriegst du ja meistens so ein 5 Seiten PDF-Briefing mit allen möglichen Dingen dabei, sonst wie.
Und da habe ich auch schon gesagt, so ein paar Punkte, also das und das, muss ich mal überlegen, mir fällt jetzt gerade nichts ein.
So das und das ist nichts, was ich sagen würde.
Am besten sind immer noch die Briefings, da muss ich ja immer kecken, am besten sind diese Briefings, die dir dann erzählen,
ja, dieses, das, was weiß ich, wenn es um irgendein Mobile-Game oder irgendein Billig-Pay-To-Win-Game geht,
so bestes Game im XY-Ranking, super Reviews, irgendwie alle sind begeistert von diesen,
und da wird dann immer verwiesen auf Seiten und Rankings und irgendwelche, von denen ich im Leben noch nichts gehört habe.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen wie die ganzen Versicherungen und sonst was in Deutsch und Supermärkte und so,
alle zeigen sich, wir sind wieder Testsieger, wir haben in der Verbraucherumfrage gewonnen,
und da guckst du dann nach, okay, okay, wo denn, wo denn, und dann stellst du fest, ah, okay, in irgendeiner Zeitschrift,
die von euch gesponsert wird, alles klar, da habt ihr gewonnen, ja, ganz toll.
Also, wie gesagt, es steht einem ja frei, den Bedingungen zuzustimmen oder nicht,
das heißt, da muss man sich im Nachhinein nicht beschweren, dass die so böse waren auf irgendwas bestanden haben.
Also, wenn zu mir jemand sagt, hey Max, wir würden gerne, dass du unsere neue Maus vorstellst,
aber, keine Ahnung, du sollst sagen, wie super weich sich die Oberfläche anfühlt, ja,
und die Oberfläche ist rau, ich kann den Leuten noch keinen Mist erzählen,
kannst du sagen, ja gut, das können wir so nicht sagen, du weißt ja vorher, ja,
und am besten ist immer, wenn sie dir dann ein Skript schicken, da muss ich auch immer cringen,
also manchmal ist es so, die schicken dir einfach nur ein, die schicken dir einfach nur so ein Briefing,
da steht dann drinne, ja, bestes Game ever, und du kannst dir ein paar Punkte raussuchen und gut ist, so.
Dann kannst du was zu sagen, meistens wollen die das Video vorher sehen, was ich aber auch vollkommen okay finde,
dass du nicht da irgendwas hinrotzt, was ihnen überhaupt nicht gefällt.
Okay, so, und dann hast du welche, die sind super spezifisch und schreiben dir sogar einen Skript,
und ich müsste das echt mal raussuchen, die Genshin Impact Leute, die haben mir einen Skript geschickt, Leute,
das war ein Sponsoring, glaube ich, für 60 Sekunden, und die haben mir einen Skript geschickt von über einer A4 Seite,
für 60 Sekunden, ich weiß nicht, wie die sich das vorstellen, wie das funktionieren soll,
und ich habe das schon runtergerattert, es, fuck, und da haben immer noch Sachen gefehlt draus,
die waren aber irgendwie der Meinung, okay, das muss in die 60 Sekunden rein,
und in 90 Sekunden waren es, glaube ich, 90 Sekunden, das war nicht machbar, das war absolut nicht machbar,
ich habe dann einfach ein paar Sachen übersprungen, und es hat am Ende keinen interessiert,
aber das war schon weird champ, die hatten ein super detailliertes Skript, das war über eine A4 Seite lang,
einfach zweifache Geschwindigkeit, warte mal, wer es nicht kennt, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste,
welches Video war das mit meinem Genshin-Sponsoring, mal kurz gucken, Genshin,
hier, hier, hier, wer es nicht kennt, wird sich jetzt wahrscheinlich kaputt lachen, Sponsoring,
okay, achten, mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke stimmt,
beziehungsweise das Game hätte Potenzial gehabt, und für wenn es sich lohnt, wieder reinzugucken,
Sponsoring-Time, verkaufen sollte, das erzähle ich euch gleich,
und das bringt mich auch zum Partner des heutigen Videos, Genshin Impact ist ein Open-World-Adventure-Game
mit einer großen Anzahl verschiedener Charaktere im Anime-Style,
viel schneller geht es nicht mehr, oder?
Genshin Impact ist für PS5, PS4, PC, auch für Mobile-Geräte, iOS und Android erhältlich,
die große atmosphärische offene Welt lädt dich ein Tifa zu erforschen, eine Welt voller Geheimnis in der es...
ich muss diese, ich muss diese am Vierseite irgendwie vorlesen, 130, in eineinhalb Minuten, 90 Sekunden,
in 90 Sekunden muss ich das irgendwie vorlesen,
...7 Regionen, 7 Göttern, wie könnte das anders sein, auch 7 Elemente gibt, die kombiniert werden können,
um neue Synergien zu schaffen und noch mehr coole Angriffe auszuführen,
die geschlossene Karte von Genshin, wenn man nur, Mondstadt, Lio, Sumero mitzählt, ist mehr als 50...
Ich hab absolut keinen Plan, wovon ich rede...
...900 Fußballfelder in der realen Welt, das Spiel hat regelmäßige Inhaltsupdates,
wie den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch 3.1, der neue aufregende Region, wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüsten...
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste...
Das ist doch schlecht, Max, das wollten die, dass ich das eins zu eins sage,
ich sollte sagen, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, also hab ich halt gesagt, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste...
...Region, wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann die Geheimnisse...
Das ist so schlecht, Alter...
...aufregende Region, wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste,
aber ich kann die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen in Sumero erkunden...
...und es gibt drei...
Das ist so schlecht...
...neue Helden im Spiel...
...Sino, ein 5-Sterne-Elektro, Cailans, ein 4-Sterne-Hyper...
Ich muss mich hier mal wegpissen, wenn ich mein eigenes Sponsoring fahre...
Das ist so schlecht, Alter...
Das war nicht meine Idee, das so zu erzählen, die wollen unbedingt, dass ich sage, ich war noch nie in einer Wüste...
...oh, wie toll ist es, das Wüstengebiet zu erkunden oder sowas...
Was machst du denn, ja? Aber immerhin, Sponsoring, Werbung...
...beide recht mächtig und schließlich...
...recht mächtig sind sie alle...
...oh man...
...alder...
...so viel zum Thema Sellout auf YouTube...
...kommt in dem Video eigentlich noch was...
...das gesagt hat, dass sie geflunkert hat, also es ist ja nichts anderes als ein Beweis dafür...
...ich spreche ja nicht so gut Deutsch, deswegen kann ich nur die Hälfte davon verstehen...
...also ich fand, um ehrlich zu sein und das jetzt mal völlig neutral, ich fand es einfach an den Haaren herbeigezogen...
...und fand, es waren einfach faule Ausreden für ein...
Ja ach, wer hätte das gedacht, Instagram Influencer bringen faule Ausreden...
...wer hätte damit, wer hätte da, das hätte ich ja nie mit gerechnet...
...schwamm drüber, das Internet ist ja leider vergesslich und...
...ja, es werden weiter fleißig Werbungen gemacht für Sachen, die nicht so cool sind...
...dementsprechend konnte ich leider auch mit...
Das Internet, das Internet ist ja geil, ich weiß was er meint, aber muss man sagen...
...das ist eigentlich das Gegenteil der Fall, das Internet ist nicht vergesslich...
...die Leute sind vergesslich...
...und du findest im Internet alles wieder, also wenn einer in 20 Jahren nach Hydro Hype sucht...
...da kann er sich das angucken, kann sich denken, Alter, was haben die Leute denn 2020 da getrieben...
...so viel auf der Influencer Seite bewirken, denn es werden weiterhin leuchtende Zahnschienen beworben...
...die nachweislich nicht funktionieren, es wird weiterhin Werbung für alle möglichen Scheiß gemacht...
...ich bin froh, dass ich auf der anderen Seite der Medaille was bewirken konnte, denn...
...ich habe das Gefühl, dass seit Hydro Hype und dann auch nochmal durchhole die Zuschauer...
Äh ne, ist es nicht...
...also er schreibt dieses Info jetzt doch teilweise schon hin, wenn die Hersteller sowas akzeptieren...
...das ist die Frage, was die vorhaben, und du weißt doch gar nicht, wie das angekommen ist...
...es ist durchaus möglich, dass viele Leute es downgeloadet haben...
...gerade, weil das Sponsoring irgendwo noch besser gepasst hat bei mir, das kann man...
...also das ist ein super komplexes Feld, ob sich was lohnt oder nicht...
...das kann man so pauschal gar nicht sagen, du kannst die beschissenste Werbung machen für irgendwas...
...die wirklich so schlecht ist, dass alle cringen und es kann super erfolgreich sein...
...das ist immer davon abhängig, was man eigentlich erreichen will...
...und es ist ein super komplexes Themengebiet...
...das glaube ich nicht, dass die Leute...
...also bei mir nicht, die Leute werden das bei mir nicht geglaubt haben...
...aber ich weiß, dass sich trotzdem einige runtergeladen haben...
...ich habe keine Statistik am Ende bekommen, aber so sehr interessiert es mich auch nicht...
...Zuschauer einfach kritischer mit Werbung umgehen...
...und einfach auch nochmal hinterfragen, wenn das Wort Werbung in irgendeiner Ecke steht...
...wobei man muss auch sagen, viele hochkarätige, jahrelang etablierte Influencer...
...sind immer noch nicht ihre Werbung vernünftig zu markieren...
Ja, das finde ich auch verwerflich...
...das ist das, womit ich dann tatsächlich...
...was ich als problematisch empfinde...
...wenn das nicht markiert ist als Werbung...
...also mir reicht es ja schon...
...am besten ist natürlich, wenn oben so ein Werbeblock...
...mir reicht es auch theoretisch schon, wenn es in der Beschreibung steht...
...oder aber wenn einer sagt, dieses Video ist unterstützt von XY...
...oder das folgende wurde mir zur Verfügung...
...es muss in irgendeiner Art und Weise kenntlich sein...
...am besten ist natürlich oben in der Ecke, eine Einblendung...
...aber das muss ja nicht zwangsläufig sein...
...das finde ich persönlich am besten...
...aber so gar nichts erwähnen und noch zusätzlich es zu verschleiern...
...und so zu tun, als hat man das Produkt zufällig im Aldi gefunden...
...das ist natürlich problematisch...
...find ich auch sehr, sehr ärgerlich...
...könnte man ja auch mal überlegen, ein Projekt drüber zu machen...
...egal, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist...
...dass die Leute, die meine Videos schauen...
...einfach jetzt, sag ich mal, geschulter sind...
...und gewiefter an die Sache rangehen...
...und sich nicht von vorne und hinten was vom Pferd erzählen lassen...
...und das merke ich vor allem in den Situationen...
...die mir persönlich nahegehen, wo ich wirklich stolz bin...
...was ein Ritterschlag...
Kommt in dem Video noch irgendwas dazu?
Nee, oder?
Können wir doch komplett skippen?
Eigentlich kommt dazu gar nichts Spannendes mehr...
Hier ist der Chat auch 5-Hat...
Ja, das stimmt...
Der Chat ist extrem 5-Hat...
High IQ Chat...
Nur hier...
Moin...
Battlefield Update 3.2...
Moment, wirklich?
Ist das schon Season 4?
Nee?
Nee, doch, doch, oder?
Ja, was denn nun?
Ist das nicht Season 4?
Nee, es ist 3.
Ach, 3 ist noch Season 3, okay.
First Major Game Update 2023...
Bla, bla, bla...
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht...
Ihr returnt gar nicht wirklich zum Klassen-System...
Ihr behaltet das Specialist-System nur...
...dass es ein paar Einschränkungen gibt, wer was nehmen kann...
...und ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, das wird richtige Abfuck...
Die Fahrzeuge sind in Battlefield 2042 zum größten Teil absolut crap...
...bis auf ein paar Helis, die jetzt schon mega krass sind...
...und als meint ihr, was passiert, wenn die beliebtesten Specialists...
...nicht Heli geiern können...
...dann gibt's noch mehr auf den Sack...
...von Helis...
Also da bin ich mal echt gespannt, ob das...
Oh, Breakaway!
Okay, die Map hat's auch wirklich...
...nötig.
Die Map ergibt danach dann zwar überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr...
...weil die Ölbohrstation quasi in der Küste steckt...
...aber okay, das kann ja alles sein.
Exclusive Rewards kriegen wir, Leute.
Das wird was.
Das wird was, Leute.
Ein Buff für Helis...
...und das nicht mehr jeder Anti-Air nehmen kann.
Na, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Aber wie gesagt, es ändert sich ja gar nicht so grundlegend, was...
...die Specialist nur, das bleibt alles da.
Das Einzige, was passiert ist, dass...
...jeder Specialist, der ja eigentlich jetzt schon eine Kategorie hat...
...es wird ein bisschen umsortiert...
...dann Gadget-Beschränkungen kriegt.
Also du kannst da nicht mehr...
...Anti-Tank-Sachen als Assault mitnehmen und sowas.
Bist du nicht bei EA Creator Network?
Das kannst du vergessen.
Die laden mich nie wieder zu irgendwas ein.
Never. Die laden mich nie wieder ein.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Versuchen? Nee.
Ich...
Ich versuch das auch gar nicht.
Dafür interessiert es mich nicht mehr genug.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich hab Sponsoring damals angenommen zu Battlefield 2042.
Ich hab auch die drei Videos dafür produziert.
Und zwischendurch hab ich halt ein, zwei Videos hochgeladen...
...wo ich sage, was Sache ist mit dem Game.
Und ich glaube, seitdem laden die mich nie wieder ein.
Ist mir aber auch scheißegal, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich kann die Spiele mir auch so angucken.
Kein Sponsoring, irgendwelches Early Access und sonst was.
Okay, also ich kann...
...meine Lieblingskombi...
...kann ich nach wie vor spielen.
McKay, Midi-Pen, alles gut?
Gadgets.
Ah nee, kann ich nicht.
Ich hab immer...
Ich hab immer Midi-Pen...
...und Motion-Sensor gespielt, das geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, das ist auch okay so.
Repairt?
Das ist insgesamt besser Spiel, glaub ich dir sogar.
Das ist ja nicht mehr so viel Spam vom gleichen.
Gut, Repairtool.
Seriously, irgendjemand hat das Spiel...
...irgendwer mal gespielt und wurde repariert im Fahrzeug?
Ich glaube, ich wurde nicht einmal in irgendeinem Fahrzeug repariert in diesem Spiel.
Recon gibt's ganze zwei?
Ja, okay.
Ja, wir probieren das aus, wir probieren das aus.
Wann gibt's denn?
Wann kommt denn das raus?
Gibt's da schon Release Date?
Release Date?
Am 20...
...nicht so ganz.
Okay, also gibt's ja...
Wenn's noch Januar kommen soll, gibt's ja nicht so viele Möglichkeiten.
Okay, alles klar.
Yep, das gucken wir uns nächste Woche mal an.
Da muss ich erstmal den Kram wieder...
Da muss ich mir auf dem neuen Rechner wahrscheinlich die EA-App installieren...
...oder irgend so ein Crap.
Dann können wir mal gucken, wie gut es auf dem neuen Rechner läuft.
Dann haben wir mal den direkten Vergleich.
13900K 4090 versus 8700K 1080 Ti.
Sollte schon ein bisschen besser laufen.
Okay, was können wir uns anschauen?
I've tested...
Okay, lass mal durchgucken, ob das Video was taugt.
Ich hab von dem noch nie was geguckt.
13 Millionen Subscriber.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eher was...
...keine Ahnung.
Hey, so eine hatte ich auch mal.
Erinnert sich noch einer an das Video?
Erinnert sich noch einer an mein Video?
Max FPS Zahnbürste.
Wo ist denn das Video hin?
Da ist es doch!
Die Pro Gamer Zahnbürste.
Ich hatte auch mal so ein Teil.
Mit Bluetooth.
Alter, ich bin im falschen Browser, deswegen.
Okay, 5000 Gadgets.
Mal gucken, ob das Video was taugt.
Ich glaube eher nicht, aber mal gucken.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was in YouTube-Videos so aktuell ist.
Es darf kein Bild sein, wo sich nicht irgendwas bewegt.
Essenziell, ganz wichtig.
Okay, naja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Übrigens, für den meisten Müll braucht man überhaupt keinen Deckel.
Nur mal so.
Denn der einzige Mülleimer, der einen Deckel braucht, ist Biomüll.
Du brauchst für Plastikmüll keinen Deckel, du brauchst für Papiermüll keinen Deckel.
So hab ich das übrigens auch.
Ich hab hier so zwei kleine Tonnen stehen.
Ja, Restmüll, Biomüll.
Dafür brauchst du einen Deckel, genau.
Also ich hab hier für Papier und Plastik.
Ich hab so zwei kleine Tonnen.
Das sind ja keine Tonnen, das sind eher so Trage.
Ich glaub ursprünglich waren das irgendwelche Wäschetrage-Dinger.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab so zwei kleine Plastiktonnen stehen.
Eins für Papier und eins für Plastik.
Die haben keinen Deckel.
Wozu brauchen die Deckel?
Der stinkt ja nix von.
Das wäre mir viel zu umständlich, wenn ich ein bisschen Papier wegschmeißen müsste.
Erstmal die Hand über den Mülleimer zu waven.
Oder zu sagen, hier Mülleimer geh auf und so was.
Am besten noch rein über Proprietäre Cloud mein Mülleimer steuern.
Und das Schöne an meinen zwei Tonnen ist, da passt auch einiges rein.
Und ohne dass ich das vorher irgendwie kleingrempeln muss.
Das wird einfach genommen.
Also ich könnte jetzt von hier zum Beispiel.
Machen wir das mal.
Hier.
Ich weiß nicht ob ihr das hört.
Ich nehme jetzt mal was.
So hier zack.
Ich hab jetzt was.
Und jetzt könnte ich einfach so hier Achtung Leute.
Hier so zack.
Weiß ich ob man's gehört hat.
Und schon liegt's im Müll.
Quer, quer übers Zimmer.
Oder nur das halbe Zimmer gepfeffert.
Da trifft man auch vom Schreibtisch aus.
Naja gut.
Weiter.
Wisst ihr was auch schön Anti-Fingerprint ist?
Plastik.
Naja.
Ok.
Nice to have.
Besten.
Kannst du was empfehlen?
Äääh, nee.
Also MW2 ist überhaupt nicht meins.
WS2 ist auch überhaupt nicht meins.
Das letzte Battlefield ist auch verkackt.
Nope.
Dass die zwei Sachen kannst du.
Wenn du da den Spaß an den alten Teile hattest.
Eigentlich nahezu vergessen.
Death Operator.
Danke für den Sub.
Ansonsten.
Du kannst die alten Teile spielen.
Es geht immer noch.
Tja, nee, ansonsten kann ich dir leider nichts empfehlen.
Wie kommst du mit Windows 11 zurecht?
Ja, gezwungenermaßen muss ich mit Windows 11 zurechtkommen.
Großen Bock hab ich nicht drauf, ich mein, ich war schon nicht sonderlich scharf drauf.
Auf die Windows 10 Bedienung.
Aber Windows 11 hat noch ein paar Sachen oben drauf gesetzt.
Zum Beispiel, dass ich diesen Platz in meiner Taskleiste nicht sinnvoll benutzen kann für
irgendwas.
Weil alle meine Fenster zwangsgruppiert sind, ich weiß nicht, was ich Microsoft dabei gedacht
hab.
Guck mal, ich hab so viel Platz in meiner Taskleiste und da ist einfach nix.
Ja, das könnte man machen, aber ich sehs nicht ein, dass man da dran...
Also ja, wahrscheinlich werd ich sowas auch mal machen oder ich probier mal irgendeinen
Launcher aus.
Aber es kann auch nicht sein, dass das so verkackt wird.
Hättest du auch mal Lust auf ein Singleplayer-Game?
Klar, wenn's wieder was Gescheites gibt.
So, erstmal Gadgets fertig kommen, was gibt's für noch für Pongas Gadgets?
Achja.
Okay, also es ist wirklich so, die Kamera darf in diesem Video keine Sekunde stillstehen,
sonst schalten die Leute ab.
Leute, meint ihr, das ist wirklich sein Haus oder das ist irgendeine Kulisse zum Aufnehmen?
So wirklich sicher kann man sich da ja nicht sein.
Das haben wir uns doch letztens angeguckt.
Wir haben uns doch letztens die Thermos-Kerne von denen angeguckt und sind zu dem Schluss
gekommen, dass das absolut unsinniger Kram ist.
Wieso versuchst du nicht komplett auf Linux umzusteigen?
Dazu hab ich ein Video gemacht.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows, da sag ich eigentlich alles, was ich zu gesteigen
einfach mal umdenke.
Kurz gesagt, es gibt halt ein paar Sachen, wo ich dann wahrscheinlich nicht machen könnte.
Also gerade was Gaming und Content-Produktion angeht mit der Software, an die ich gewohnt
bin, kannst du vergessen unter Linux.
Du kriegst es vielleicht ein bisschen gefrickelt teilweise zum Laufen, aber wozu?
Die beste Kombination ist einfach beides zu verwenden.
Ich verwende Linux für so ziemlich alles, was auch nur entfernt mit Technik und Basteln
zu tun hat und Windows für Gaming und Content und Streaming.
Das ist eigentlich die beste Kombination, die es gibt.
Sorry, sorry.
Linux, wenn wir das nicht richtig sagen, ihr wisst was passiert, wenn wir das nicht richtig
sagen, dann ist er am Start, dann wird das Stream direkt GNU-Band.
Selbstverständlich ist es GNU-Linux.
Also.
Seriously, wenn ich meine Kaffeetasse-Firmware updaten muss, man könnte sagen, ich bin technikfeindlich,
aber ich glaube, wer sich meine Streams anguckt, wird feststellen, es ist das Gegenteil der
Fall.
Aber man muss nicht jeden Scheiß machen, der geht.
Ganz ehrlich, die Tee-Tasse finde ich sogar ganz gut.
Diese Thermos-Kanne, die es von denen gegeben hat, die wir uns das letzte Mal angeguckt haben,
die fand ich bescheuert.
Die Tasse selbst, das leuchtet mir sogar noch ein.
Das ist etwas, was ich sogar mal ausprobieren würde, was kostet denn sowas?
Was ich ein Try geben würde, Alter, ich kann nicht mehr normal reden.
Was ist mit denen los, man?
Unter der Haube ist es doch im Endeffekt eine Platte, die wahrscheinlich per Induktion oder
so den Boden von der Tasse heizt.
Das ist jetzt wieder der Punkt, wisst ihr?
Ich könnte mir das theoretisch kaufen, das ist kein Ding, also am Geld soll es da nicht
scheitern, aber ich sehe es einfach nicht ein, ich sehe es nicht ein 200 Euro dafür auszugeben.
Wahrscheinlich sind die Alternativ-Dinger genauso, genauso gut.
Im Zweifelsfalle ist die Tasse eher schneller leer als kalt, mal gucken, wie viel da rein
passt.
Also ich habe hier so 0,7er Tassen, die sind relativ groß.
Da habe ich zum Beispiel jetzt auch gerade Tee drin, was auch relativ lange hält, weil
die Tasse so groß ist.
Wie viel passt denn da rein?
300ml?
Okay, das ist jetzt 300ml, das musst du doch nicht, das musst du doch nicht warm halten.
Was?
14 Fluid-Oz?
Hell yeah!
Freedom Unit, okay, was sind 14 Fluid-Oz in Milliliter, 414ml, alles klar, okay, also
es passt ein bisschen mehr als die Hälfte rein.
Also wenn ich meine 0,7er, 0,7er, das ist ein großer, großer Becher hier, also wenn
ich diesen 0,7er Becher quasi so zu, so über die Hälfte voll mache, dann ist, naja, ganz
ehrlich, das musst du gar nicht lange wärmen, weil das wahrscheinlich in einer halben Stunde
eh leer getrunken ist.
Naja, okay, nee, ich glaube, das probiere ich nicht aus.
Okay, wenn man eineinhalb Stunden braucht für 400ml, dann macht es vielleicht Sinn.
Ist das, spritzt das Wasser im Mund rum oder wie?
Also quasi ein Hochdruckreiniger für die Zähne sozusagen.
Ja, weiß nicht, ob das was bringt, könnte, achso, da geht es gar nicht drauf.
Zungenreinigung, macht das Sinn, bringt das irgendwas, Zungenreinigung, also ein extra
Zungenreinigungsmode, wenn man irgendwas hängen hat, kann man ja auch die normale Bürste nehmen,
also braucht man einen extra Zungenreinigungsmodus.
Okay, das hat meine, also meine Zahnbürste hat das auch, die vibriert dann leicht.
Wenn, wenn ich zu hart drücke, GajiBuzz, hat das auch eine Smartphone App, die nur über
die schöne Chinesen-Cloud geht, dann kann ich das auch machen, wenn ich zu hart drücke,
dann kann ich das auch machen, wenn ich zu hart drücke, dann kann ich das auch machen,
wenn ich zu hart drücke, dann kann ich das auch machen, wenn ich zu hart drücke, dann
kann ich das auch machen, wenn ich zu hart drücke, dann kann ich das auch machen, wenn
ich zu hart drücke, dann kann ich das auch machen, wenn ich zu hart drücke, dann kann
Ich würde jetzt auch nicht mehr kaufen, sondern wenn überhaupt das neueste Modell und ich
muss dazu sagen, leider, sind die nur noch sehr schwierig zu flashen diese Dinger.
Und deswegen kommen sie für mich nicht mehr in Frage, obwohl ich gerne mal einen Staubsauger
Roboter ausprobieren würde, der eine Entleerungsstation hat.
Das ist nämlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich auf meinen keinen Bock habe.
Ich habe nämlich noch einen Roborock S5 und der hat keine Ausleerstation, da muss man
quasi laufend runterkriechen zur Ladestation und das auswechseln und den rumdrehen und
so.
Das ist halt doof.
Ja, die Dreamy Geschichten kämen vielleicht auch noch in Frage, aber auch nur weil man
sie gescheit flashen kann.
Das ist der Grundflur, mit dem man die Ladestation ausprobieren kann, automatisch
schwerer zu füllen, wenn es über dicken Karpeten ist, und dann bei sich selbst zurück
zu sein, wenn es fertig ist.
Das ist das Beste, was wir hier haben.
Du wirst über eine längere Zeit realisieren, dass es einige Probleme gibt, die es einfach
nicht mag.
Dieser Schraub hier ist ein wenig zu hoch, um ihn zu steigern, aber dann muss man nur
in die App gehen und ihn als No-Go-Zone setzten, und es wird einfach alles anderes machen.
Aber es ist noch halb die ganze Zeit, die wir in diesem Haus vakuumieren.
Und 90% von dem ist deine Schuld, nicht wahr?
So, Nummer 5 dann, wir haben hier meine Earphones.
Ich verwirre die Laptop-Speaker, wenn ich meine eigenen Videos höre, denn das ist
eher ein Beispiel dafür, wie sie zu dir klingen werden.
Aber wenn ich mich auf ein paar Freunde auf den Go oder Musik höre, sind die Earphones,
die ich für reiche, die AirPods Pro 2.
Und ich würde sagen, dass es ungefähr 50% eine Anwendung ist.
Wenn du Apple-Produkte benutzt, sind AirPods einfach so unabhängig.
Du hast Zugang zu Siri.
Ich muss ja ehrlich sagen, wenn die AirPods die gleiche Form haben, wie diese normalen
iPhone-Kopfhörer, dann sind meine Ohrmuscheln nicht gemacht für Apple-geformte Kopfhörer.
Du wirst lachen, er schreibt, ich kaufe mir erst, wenn die Dinge auch die Fliesen wischen,
das geht.
Wenn du dir einen der ganz neuen kaufst, haben die sogar in der Entleerungstation einen
Wassertank, den man so entleeren kann, dass es nicht anfängt zu stinken.
Das geht, die haben einen Lappen, die können die Fliesen wischen und die können das Wasser
wechseln.
Die ganz neuen.
Lappen hat meiner auch, habe ich aber noch nie verwendet.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, selbst wenn ich einen hätte mit Station für Wasser und Lappen,
ich würde wahrscheinlich nur Teppichboden, ich habe hier auch nur Teppichboden, das einzige,
wo ich Fliesen habe, ist im Bad, im Flur und unten im Bad und in der Küche, das sind
keine Fliesen, da ist es halt glatt, aber da brauche ich keinen Staubsaugeropper dafür,
da kommt eh nicht die Treppe hoch und runter.
Was kostet ein neuer, ist relativ teuer, ich glaube 600, 700 Euro muss man für die Neuesten
mit Absaugstationen sogar schon rechnen, wenn nicht sogar mehr, das ist nicht billig.
Was ist eigentlich aus Beats geworden, die hat Apple ja auch gekauft.
Dr Dre Beats, by the way, ich mag, ich mag auch keine, äh, Kugeln, Kugeln, Kugeln, Kugeln,
äh, Kopfhörer, die in ihr sind, die mit diesen Gummis, die sich so an die Ohren anlegen,
das kann ich maximal eine halbe Stunde, Stunde anhaben, dann wird es unangenehm.
Das könnte auch was anderes sein.
Ja Leute, merkt ihr auch, was für krasse Tension ihr bei euch im Forehead habt.
Also mein Forehead ist so tense, ja ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt bringen die LEDs da vorne irgendwas
rein.
Was?
Jetzt bin ich jetzt, okay man trinkt Wasser, was beim Trinken so schmeckt, wie, was schmeckt,
wie gezuckertes oder halt, äh, tja, mit Geschmack.
Okay, ah ja.
Okay.
und die Erwartungen, die du hast, gehen rein.
Weil, wenn du eine von diesen kaufst,
erwartest du, dass sie Wasser in Juice werden können,
nur durch den Geruch,
wirst du völlig falsch.
Es ist eher so, als würde es den Wasser einen notizablen Geruch geben,
und dann ein bisschen...
By the way, wie wäre es mit einfach Wasser trinken?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar nicht das Bedürfnis dafür,
dass mein Wasser nach irgendwas schmeckt.
Wenn ich will, dass mein Wasser nach irgendwas schmeckt,
ähm, trinke ich Tee.
Das ist dann zwar kein Wasser mehr,
aber das schmeckt nach was.
Aber das ist genug für mich,
um von meinem Bottle viel mehr zu erreichen,
als ich sonst hätte.
Also, das macht eine große Unterschiede in meinem Leben.
Aber, noch mehr wichtig für mein dagestes Leben
ist mein Smartphone.
Ja gut, das ist klar.
Es gibt eigentlich zwei, die ich jetzt benutze.
Das Hauptphone, das ich überall habe
und alle meiner arbeitlichen Dinge mache,
ist das iPhone 14 Pro Max.
Es ist nicht das Impressionierendste,
das ich jemals mit einem iPhone war.
Die Batterie ist etwas schwächer als die der letzten Generation.
Die Kameras bekommen viel Dust
und sie sind etwas schwer zu rösten.
Und ich habe die Always-on-Display
aufgelöst,
die eine der neuen Features ist,
die ich mitlauchte.
Aber, mit einem iPhone
ist mein Backphone
auch sehr komfortabel,
weil, A,
die klare Weise, wie ich meine Freundin spreche,
ist durch die Stimme.
Und sie klingen so viel besser,
als sie es mit Android machen.
Oh, warte mal!
Du wirst es nicht glauben.
Das neue Samsung-Phone
kommt mit einer 200-Megapixel-Kamera.
Das ist, das ist so spannend, oder?
Sicher?
B, sowohl ich,
als auch viele von den wichtigen Leuten um mich
benutzen Apple-Produkte.
Also, dass ich sie FaceTime kann,
hat in höheren Qualität-Kollegen geschehen,
wenn wir versuchen,
die Logistik eines Weihnachts zu koordinieren.
Und, dass ich sie einfach
die Fotos von unseren aktuellsten Begegnungen
herstellen kann, ist ein genügendes Zeitbewerb.
Und C,
als ich anfange, mehr zu machen...
Wie gut ist denn ein iPhone?
Ich muss mir auch noch ein neues iPhone kaufen jetzt,
weil ich wechsle ja den Arbeitgeber
zum ersten, vierten
und das iPhone,
was ich aktuell verwende,
ist von der Firma gesponsert.
Das muss ich zurückgeben.
Ich bekomme wahrscheinlich ein neues Smartphone
im neuen Job.
Wahrscheinlich auch ein iPhone,
aber ich kaufe mir endlich mal ein eigenes,
mit eigenem Vertrag dabei,
dass ich das hin und her nicht mehr habe.
Das stimmt.
Das ist halt das Blöde an den Kameras,
dass sie überstehen, ne?
Du kannst das Handy nicht mal flach
auf den Tisch legen, ohne Case drum herum.
Und, wenn du eh
einen Case drum herum brauchst,
stellst du halt komplett in Frage,
warum du den Kram am Anfang erst so dünn baust.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Sein Smart-Klo.
Leute, ich call's jetzt.
Der hat auch einen Smart-Klo.
Das ist das beste.
Das ist ja lame.
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt irgendwas Spannendes.
Nah dran, ja.
Fast ein Klo.
Mein New Desktop.
Oh, der stellt uns ein i3 vor.
Ich glaub, das ist jetzt ein bisschen harte Kost.
Was ist das?
Ich habe 72 Stunden
nur mit VR-Branchen.
Das ist ja ein bisschen...
Okay, zeig mal her.
72 Stunden, nicht an meinem Computer, sondern...
Moment, ist das nicht der Kerl,
den wir letzte Woche auch schon geguckt haben?
Der, wartet mal, der hat doch
letzte Woche, haben wir doch ein Video geguckt.
Da hat er seine Wohnung
gezeigt.
Irgendwas Miesemaliges.
Was ist das denn?
Gezeigt irgendwas,
meine super Hightech-Wohnung
oder sowas.
Und wo wir uns gefragt haben, wo genau
ist jetzt eigentlich der Hightech.
Naja, der Zuck denkt sich das vielleicht.
Nee, das ist nicht der mit der 5000-Euro-Kafemaschine,
das mit der 5000-Euro-Kafemaschine,
Kaffeemaschine das war der Küchen der Küchenplaner
Und was die Nachteile
Das ist die MetaQuest 2 für 350 euro und das die MetaQuest Pro die neue Hightech Brille für
1800 euro und der Unterschied zwischen den beiden die ist jetzt die ist jetzt rund das ist schon mal 700 euro mehr wert
schon beim ersten tragen deutlich auf 36 prozent schärfere Displays mit 5 es sieht auch es sieht auch ehrlich gesagt leichter
und bequemer aus
sind höherem Kontrast das ist als würde man HD mit Full HD vergleichen außerdem sind die Linsen schärfer und haben nicht mehr dieses komische
glühen um helle Elemente herum die Brille ist insgesamt weniger
Frontlastig und erkennt selbstständig wie sie auf dem Gesicht sitzt sie zeigt an was ich tun muss um den Sitz zu optimieren hier ein bisschen höher da
Mal kurz drehen und fertig das ist möglich alles Kameras gibt die auf das Gesicht schauen und das funktioniert so gut dass ich einen virtuellen
Avatar habe der meine Mimik und G-Stick nachahmend es liegen zwei Kontrolle am Lieferumfang bei aber die braucht man gar nicht
Kameras erfassen die Hände Arme und sogar Finger und das alles ist tatsächlich mal eine gute Neuerung selbst mit ihrem
Snapdragon xr 2 plus Prozessor für mein Experiment verbinde ich meinen normalen Computer
Kabellos mit der Meta Workspace App und ich bediene alles ganz normal über Tastatur und Maus die ich in der virtuellen Welt sehen kann
Weil ein Videofenster von der echten Welt ausgeschnitten wird und ich sage euch es ist wirklich skurril diesen Übergang zwischen
Echten Händen und digitalen Händen zu erleben jetzt wo alles eingerichtet ist beginnt Tag 1 bis zu drei Monitore schweben vor mir
Sie sind etwa 48 zoll groß und haben eine meine das ruckelt alles oder
ruckelt das alles
Das das wirkt das wirkt so ruckelig ich kann Fenster hin und her schieben Musik über die Computer Lautsprecher
Das liegt da wahrscheinlich an der Kopfbewegung selbst hören
Letztere sind qualitativ so la la aber für ein bisschen Video schauen geht schon klar cool finde ich dass sich der Ton
Relativ zu meinen Kopfbewegungen mit bewegt wenn ich von einem Video weg schaue dann wandert auch der Ton weg
gewöhnliche Office Aufgaben wie Mails beantworten Inhalte recherchieren Dokumente bearbeiten das alles funktioniert absolut
Problemlos und nach kurzer Eingewöhnung die frage ist halt nur wenn das problemlos funktioniert
Was ist also warum sollte man es machen das funktioniert ohne Brille genauso problemlos
Habe ich fast vergessen dass es die Monitore gar nicht wirklich gibt es fühlt sich alles so an wie sonst auch ich kann relativ gut
Aber nicht perfekt blind tippen ich kann aber die Tastatur durch die 3d Kameras der Brille sehen oder ich kann am unteren Rand der
Brille vorbeischauen und das hilft sehr ich bearbeite also in der Meta Quest das Video über die Meta Quest was ganz schön Meter ist
Normalerweise sitze ich vor einem 6k Monitor dagegen ist Fuller D natürlich deutlich
Unschärfer auch wenn ich Texte gut lesen kann das Störenste sind für mich immer die kurzen
Aussetzer und Hänger die durch die WLAN Verbindung entstehen und auch
Die Akkulaufzeit ist mit gerade mal zwei Stunden. Ja das nicht zwei Stunden
Das reicht natürlich zwei Stunden ist nichts nichts für den Arbeitstag
Zwei Stunden ist gut wenn du das zum Spielen verwendest vielleicht ab und zu mal
Um zwei Stunden zu arbeiten aber dann muss man es neu aufladen es hat jetzt in meinem fall so ein
gedauert man kann erst mal abdruck durchgängig auf dem kopf des pc einstecken und
Durchgängig am strom benutzen und ich denke so werde ich das in zukunft ja das ist dann besser
Streifen auf der Stirn ist es
denn der dauert auch eine weile bis der wieder weg ist anders als die meisten anderen wie abrillen ist die da bräuchte jetzt diesen diesen
face entspanner aus dem letzten video dann werden roten streifen ratzfahrt wieder weg
Quest pro zu den seiten und nach unten hin offen das mochte ich mehr als
dankeschön für den zapp weniger
Eingeschlossen falls es irgendwie sinn macht man kann aber auch magnetische cover dran machen um das licht komplett weg zu blocken und für gaming
Macht das schon sinn als belohnung spiele ich etwas minigolf und ich spiele sogar so schlecht wie in echt krass
Das ist super friedlich gerade wenn du gerade noch gearbeitet hast und du bist ja voll
Fühlt sich an wie eine ganz andere welt weil jetzt sitzt du nicht mehr am schreibtisch hast du deinen computer sondern du bist hier
So ist ein bisschen aussicht du schaust in die ferne ist es super friedlich schon irgendwie cool dann sieht einfach aus wie den
wichspiel super
Super
Das spiel ist aber wie gemacht für vor
Ja aus gefühlen verbrennt auf jeden fall deutlich mehr kalorien als bei jeder anderen konsole und zu guter letzt among us in 3d
Sus es ist sehr witzig in dieser spielwelt drin zu sein die man normalerweise nur von oben kennt das hier ist die erste virtuelle sponsor
ankündigung jemals denn dieses video wurde unterstützt durch reino schild
Und auch wenn ich hier in der virtuellen realität kein smartphone habe kann es mir meine
Echten realität hat immer noch runterfallen und reino schild höhen bieten den besten schutz es gibt viele coole
Modulare designs alles klar von sogar extrem krassen magsafe support ob er auch schon mal in einer wüste war
Mit diesem rabattcode bekommt ihr zehn prozent rabatt auf das gesamte sortiment von reino schild vielen dank dass ihr solche verrückten ideen überhaupt
Es möglich macht
Ja sie ist gerade ausgegangen der akku ist leer ich schätze mal das war es für heute
Der tag hat sich insgesamt ein bisschen
Diffusor aber auch kürzer angefühlt als sonst ich hatte nicht so ein richtiges
Verhältnis zur zeit ich habe nicht so richtig mitbekommen was die anderen im studium machen ich war wirklich so ein
Meiner eigenen welt aber insgesamt hat das überraschend gut funktioniert jetzt am ende des spiel hat noch richtig viel spaß gemacht
Und ich bin super gespannt auf tag zwei
Ehrlich gesagt für gaming kann ich mir das super vorstellen
Arbeiten damit sehe ich jetzt noch keinen allzu großen vorteil
Was office arbeiten dann kommt die erste herausforderung
Zumal es halt auch nervig ist den ganzen tag so ein ding aufzuhaben ich habe jetzt ein call
Und für diesen call brauche ich eine webcam und dieses ding hier kann mich zwar
Theoretisch in der meta app in 3d anzeigen in dem video call aber leider telefoniere ich nicht mit meta
Dementsprechend benutzen die diese app nicht das bedeutet ich muss mir jetzt irgendeine kreative lösung ausdenken
Zum glück kann man jetzt ein iphone als webcam nutzen
Ich habe jetzt das iphone da werden die aber ein bisschen blöd gucken oder wenn er so vor ihnen sitzt
Mit dem mac verbunden und beide wiederum streamen auf die brille
Das funktioniert alles für mich ich kann alle sehen die mit mir telefonieren wollen und ich sehe meine digitalen hände
Und letztendlich meine echten hände
Aber die sehen mich im video an
Mit dieser brille im gesicht und sie werden fragen stellen da bin ich mir sicher
Danach schneide ich etwas mein video weiter und verfeinere die notizen vom video call
Akku leer
Rote striche im gesicht 100 prozent in meinem video anruf hat niemand nachgefragt was eigentlich los ist was mega komisch war weil ich hatte so ein ding im gesicht
Aber ich habe jetzt nackenschmerzen und ich habe auch rückenschmerzen das ding wiegt über 700 gramm
Sonst hätte man ein ipad den ganzen tag lang so auf dem kopf und das spüre ich jetzt auf jeden fall
Deswegen habe ich mir auch gedacht den ganzen tag mit so einem ding so der eigene kopf ist halt immer noch beste
Ja jetzt kann ich es halt wieder aufsetzen das ist natürlich jetzt so ein bisschen so
Jetzt will ich auch mal andere menschen treffen so wie es eigentlich gedacht ist
Wreck room ist dafür beliebt aber auch etwas chaotisch es gibt lobbies wo menschen einfach sich treffen und herumlaufen können
Die grafik ist aber echt altbacken das ist so playstation 3 niveau da denke ich an vieles aber nicht an die zukunft aber irgendwie gefällt
Das das das sieht alles so billig aus dieses ganze metaverse zeug das sei ja fast second life besser aus vor 20 jahren
Ansonsten wenn die leute was ordentliches spielen wollen wo viele leute wo viele drin sind sollen sie einfach vr chat aufmachen
Ja auch wie unfertig alles noch ist es ist wie die anfänge vom internet es gibt kein algorithmus es sind einfach ein paar menschen die miteinander abhängen
Ich meine seriously sowas bauste doch in in unity oder unreal in der viertel stunde so ein raum ich habe mich gefragt wie schädlich ist es eigentlich den ganzen tag eine vr brille zu tragen
Und es gibt noch nicht so viele langzeit studien aktuell geht man davon aus dass es nicht weiter bedenklich ist man könnte zwar meinen dass der ihres muskel ermüdet weil man ja den ganzen tag so nah fokussiert
Aber der wird durch die linsen ausgetrickst tatsächlich schaut man weiter in die ferne als bei einem normalen computer dass man unser gehirn ziemlich einfach austricksen kann hat ein sonderbares experiment mit kühen verdeutlicht
den wurde eine vr brille
Die arme kuh man
Die arme kuh alter was da die kuh die hängt auch unterhalb hell ist mit mir los
Aufgezogen auf denen sie eine grüne weide gesehen haben und tatsächlich brachten sie dadurch mehr milch wer sich sorgen um bluelight macht den kann ich beruhigen denn man kann es natürlich reduzieren trotzdem habe ich gemerkt dass meine augen mehr ermüden als sonst das liegt zum einen
Ich kann es mir sogar wirklich vorstellen wenn das was bringt ja dass eine kuh mehr milch gibt es besser schmeckt oder was auch immer dann stehen demnächst alle kühe virtuell auf der grünen wiese es ist alles eine frage dessen wie teuer ist die anschaffung
Also lohnt sich das ist eigentlich das ist die eigentlich entscheidende frage mal sowas lohnt sich
Was mehr starre und weniger blinzel zum anderen sind diese etwas unschärferen texte etwas wenn ja dann wird das gemacht ja man schaut halt durchgängig auf ein display bisher wurde die brille immerhin nie heiß es sprang auch keine lüfter an heute ruckelt und lag die verbindung irgendwie deutlich mehr als gestern
ich bearbeite die aufnahmen vom vortag in meinem stück ganz anders bei super verzögert und träge das muss am wlan oder der brille selbst liegen es nervt auf jeden fall sehr und von 90 oder 120 herz kann wirklich nicht die rede sein die zeit vergeht heute nicht wie im flug sie vergeht langsam und ich habe schwierigkeiten mich zu konzentrieren ich nutze jede ausrede um die brille kurz mal abzusetzen meine nackenschmerzen und rückenschmerzen sind unerträglich geworden mein kopf tut weh und ich will die brille
ich will die brille einfach nur noch absetzen
oder die kühe auf die wiese lassen ne das geht nicht
kennt ihr das gefühl wenn ihr bei einem städtetrip über 30.000 schritte in einem tag gelaufen seid und dann am nächsten morgen wieder die schuhe anziehen müsst erst dann merkt ihr wie erschöpft eure füße eigentlich noch sind und so geht es mir heute ich gehe es also doch du kannst ein kabel anschließen kabel kannst du
anschließen das geht aber die verbindung geht wahrscheinlich immer noch über wlan lustiges video und dann in review was mich interessiert ich muss schon sagen die großen monitore sind nach wie vor klasse dann erlebe ich eine unterwasserwelt in 3d und wie jemand mit einem wingsuit aus dem helikopter springen
danach bin ich auf jeden fall euphorisch und motiviert neben meter horizon gibt es noch andere apps mit denen man den computer verbinden kann und sie funktionieren bei mir aber leider nur solala ich entscheide mich also ein bisschen den meter eigenen browser zu nutzen in dem ich meine tastatur und maus direkt mit der brille verbinde und das funktioniert alles super wenn die workrooms so flüssig und schnell wäre dann würde das für mich alles ändern obwohl die farben der brille nicht super akkurat sind mache ich mir ein bisschen
color grading und schreibe dieses skript weiter inzwischen ist mir die gestensteuerung ins blut übergegangen und ich benutze die controller wirklich nur noch dann wenn ich muss und dann nerven sie mich sogar die performance heute ist viel besser die zeit bis zur mittagspause vergeht wie im flug und als der akku leer ist stecke ich die brille einfach kurz an und benutze dann weiter in der pause gehe ich mit robert das macht dass diese brille so vielseitig ist das beeindruckt mich immer noch wie an tag eins meine visuelle realität wird einfach komplett überschrieben und deswegen ist nahezu alles möglich
ist arbeiten in virtueller realität die zukunft oder schon die gegenwart bereits 9,4 milliarden us dollar hat meter in die entwicklung gesteckt viele denken dass das ein fehler ist dass mark zuckerberg seinen verstand verloren hat und ich mag den typen auch nicht aber ich bin inzwischen überzeugt dass das die richtige entscheidung war sie wollen der pionier
muss halt sagen mit dem meta verse an sich hat es jetzt ja wenig zu tun gehabt was man gesehen hat ist eine technisch gute brille und ein paar vr anwendungen drauf ansonsten hat es ja nichts mit dem zu tun was sie was sie was sie sich da vielleicht vorstellt weiß es ja nicht mal was sie sich da so genau vorstellen
virtuelle realität sein und bald bekommen sie schon harte konkurrenz die gerüchte sind ziemlich eindeutig dass apple bereits im märz seine brille ankündigen wird und die wird in einigen punkten da bin ich mal gespannt weil wenn apple was macht dann springen die ganzen apple fanboys auf
sein als die quest pro die displays sollen allein viermal so scharf sein und dadurch wird man fast keine pixel mehr sehen kann 16 times wie war das 16 times the detail oder sowas wie war das bei fallout apple wird eine software haben die an ios erinnert nur halt was denn auch sonst schon jetzt haben sie avatare die die augen und das gesicht tracken können die an emojis außerdem können sie dank dem m2 ein viermal so starken prozessor verbauen und problemlos
ios ipad oder mac apps virtuell laufen lassen sie starten also nicht wie meta mit leeren händen sondern sie haben direkt von anfang an apps und sehr viele entwickler die hinter apple stehen auch beim thema kamera und pass-through hat apple so viel mehr erfahrungen was bildqualität angeht dass ich davon überzeugt bin dass das ganze richtig gut aussehen wird ich glaube zwar auch dass die also da bin ich auch von überzeugt gut aussehen tut das meiste zeug schlechte akkulaufzeit aber ganz ehrlich das war hier nie das problem man steckt sie einfach an und arbeitet
weiter und wenn apple dann noch megsafe verbaut ist sogar das anstecken super einfach und ich meine wem würdet ihr lieber 3000 euro geben apple oder facebook ehrlich gesagt würde ich die 3000 euro am liebsten behalten es sei dann ich krieg was richtig cooles für wo ich für mich persönlich den anwendungszweck gerade noch nicht sehe also für gaming aber für tägliches arbeiten mal gucken kann ich zurück an mein normales
setup das schöne an so selbstexperimenten ist dass man etwas was man früher für selbstverständlich hingenommen hat auf einmal wieder richtig zu schätzen lernt und jetzt gerade bin ich richtig aufgeregt darauf meinen monitor wieder in voller pracht zu sehen
richtig richtig schön scharf aus die einstiegsfrage war ist br nur so ein spielzeug oder kann man darauf auch arbeiten und die antwort ist ja man kann darauf aber die frage ist bloß warum sollte man
arbeiten und es hat viel potential und wir kratzen ja gerade erst noch die oberfläche das ist alles noch super super neu aber ich muss auch sagen das wäre natürlich auf dauer nichts für mich gewesen das wäre super anstrengend gewesen und wieder so ein monitor zu haben ohne einen roten strich im gesicht ohne dass ich nackenschmerzen kriege und kopfschmerzen das ist schon ein bisschen angenehmer auch müssen diese brillen noch kleiner werden und cooler und natürlicher aussehen und aber es hat sich schon viel getan ich meine die sieht
schon mal deutlich besser aus und macht ökonomischeren eindruck als die die ersten paar generationen 300 euro drei monitore mit voller deo und in der größe wo man sie hier drin sieht würden etwa 600 euro kosten ich für meinen teil bin jetzt umso gespannter auf die apple vr prille und auf das was die konkurrenz in nächster zeit so vorstellen wird denn ich habe die zukunft gesehen und sie ist schon viel näher als ihr denkt dann
das wissen wir bescheid oder auch nicht also ich könnte mir das nicht vorstellen damit den ganzen tag zu arbeiten am rechner aber ich mag mein zwei monitore setup auch da sind keine riesen monitore sind glaube ich 24 zoll oder so was ich hier habe
ja glaube ich bin mir ganz sicher zwei stück nebeneinander gut ist
ich persönlich mag auch zwei monitore lieber als irgendwie so ein mega single monitor
aber kann man sich unterschiedlichen geschmack haben
jetzt ein schönes katzenvideo kriegen ja keines empfohlen 99 euro mini pc bei amazon gekauft wirklich clever kommt bestimmt darauf an was man machen will
was kriege ich da für komische videos vorgeschlagen oder ich weiß ich weiß nicht mal wer ara ist
youtube versucht mir wieder irgendwelches zeug zu empfehlen
ist das legal 4,5 kilowatts solaranlage selbst installieren
ich denke mal dass das reine installieren nicht das problem ist das anschließen je nachdem wie du es verwenden willst dürfte problematisch sein dass aufs dach aufs dach bauen und so das darfst du wahrscheinlich an einem haus machen was du willst
ansonsten warum nicht gucken wir mal geht nur sieben minuten
solar module sind gerade super heiß sehr viele menschen wollen welche haben egal ob als kleines
oder so richtig groß auf dem eigenheim dach das problem ist nur man findet sehr das und es ist teuer so das komplett das bauen zu lassen
also wenn man jetzt deswegen habe ich das auch erst mal ein bisschen aufgeschoben schauen wir mal schauen wir mal wie sich das die nächsten jahre über so entwickelt
firma anruf kann es gut sein dass die sagt ja kostet 30.000 euro aber 2023 machen wir nichts mehr ja bedeutet das dass man also ein jahr lang die frische erhöhten stromkosten zahlt obwohl auf dem dach oder balkon noch so viel platz
wahrscheinlich wäre das stimmt wohl allerdings die 30.000 euro bis du die gespart hast das wird auch ein bisschen dauern aber kann man das nicht einfach selber machen das haben sie auch meine drei ct kolleginnen und kollegen jan pina und andrian gefragt die drei sind nämlich einfach zum installateur
gegangen und haben ausgehandelt dass sie die panels selber aufs dach legen und der fachbetrieb am ende alles noch prüfen und den anschluss ja das das geht wollte der dafür haben was ok ist für die arbeit und das klingt ja erst mal super viel geld sparen und zusätzlich das dach ist ganz schön voll mehr hat er nicht drauf gebast
da braucht man dafür wie schwer ist das wie lange dauert das und vor allem kriegen drei ct la gemeinsam eine komplette solar dachinstallation hin die knie haben definitiv gelitten von ihm aber das hat richtig richtig einen einsatz gezeigt das klären wir alles in diesem video bleibt dran
liebe internet surfer herzlich willkommen hier bei dieses video wird gesponsert von cyber ghost baut eine verschweißung bis 600 watt also mit zwei solar panels zählt eine anlage als balkon kraftwerk ja das darf man das darf man allerdings allerdings als ich
habe mich aber ein bisschen drüber empfohlen allerdings darfst du ein balkon kraftwerk auch nur einmal daheim hinstellen also du darfst jetzt nicht an jeden balkon ein balkon kraftwerk machen dazu haben wir ja schon zwei videos gemacht für alle
größeren dann kannst du einfach die steckdose stecken als errichter auftreten aber die beschränkung gilt nur für den anschluss ans stromnetz selbst alles was mit ziegeln schienen klemmen und gleichstrom klemmen zu tun hat
darf man im prinzip selbst machen also kollegens kann ich mein dach einfach selber mit solar vollbauen ja natürlich kann man eine photovoltaik anlage grundsätzlich auch selber installieren das ist ja warum nicht man braucht module man braucht
install also dürfen darf man sicherlich auch und man braucht wechselrichter das installationsmaterial besteht aus dachhaken die kommen auf den dachziegel unter dem dachziegel durchgeführt mit einer kleinen aussparung dann werden die festgeschraubt darauf kommen alle profil und daran werden module und wechselrichter befestigt
ok das klingt jetzt echt nicht so schwer aber kann ich das ist also ich glaube nicht dass es schwer ist in form von dass es jetzt irgendwie kompliziert ist aber es ist wahrscheinlich anstrengend es so richtig grob was falsch machen zum einen ist
jetzt so die sicherheit wenn jemand rutscht da könnte was gefährlich sein also auf dem dach arbeiten finde ich schon immer was wo ich so ein bisschen also ich ich ich hätte ich ich hätte meine bedenken in mein dach löcher zu sägen ehrlich gesagt das würde ich nur ungern machen mal ganz davon abgesehen das hier ist jetzt ja nicht sonderlich hoch also wenn hier einer runter wenn hier einer runter
fällt da passiert nichts wenn ich von meinem dach runter fallen würde da wäre ich matsch ein mundiges gefühl im bauchhabe das kannst du also das wenn ich hier runterfällt ich meine du tust dir ein bisschen weh aber viel passieren wird da wahrscheinlich nicht ansonsten die ziegeln könnten brechen wir müssen da so aussparungen machen das ist unter umständen
problem muss man aber schauen ok aber solar panels erzeugen ja gleich strom im stromnetz fließt natürlich wechselstrom da braucht man ja nur noch so ein wechselrichter wie habt ihr das denn jetzt gelöst wir haben uns aufgrund der verschattung der garage auf der wir die anlage installiert haben für mikro wechselrichter entschieden also kleine wechselrichter die direkt aufs dach kommen ans profil auf dem die solarmodule auch aufliegen das heißt nicht dass du da runterspringen sollst aber es macht einen unterschied ob du irgendwie im was ich zwei
meter höhe bist oder in zwölf meter höhe das als bei größeren strom anlagen wo die ganzen gerätschaften in der regel in den keller kommen wir haben jetzt hier zwei stück verwendet für insgesamt zwölf module direkt am profil montiert das macht ja hier auch eigentlich total
wir haben nämlich eine ziemlich schwierige situation eigentlich die garage um die es hier geht die ist teilverschattet auf der einen seite steht eine scheune auf der anderen wohnhaus dazwischen sind viele module große teile der zeit in der sonne aber immer wieder einzelne bereiche im schatten und bei einer konventionellen anlage mit einem string
ja genau ist halt die frage ob die ausrichtung hier auch so sinnvoll ist aber es ist ja nur ist es ja nur ein test ob ob sie selbst hinkriegen
wäre bei teilverschattung sofort die anlage insgesamt sehr wenig performant und mit diesen mikro wechselrichtern können wir das umgeben also die anlage der liefert ja dann mehr als vier kilowatt also auch mehr als eine normale sicherung
aushält im haus ist aber ja nicht nur mit einer phase angeschlossen sondern mit drei und über die dürfen jeweils so weit ich weiß 32 ampere fließen aber die kabel im haus müssen auch dick genug sein damit die nicht so heiß werden oder muss man da irgendwas beachten
ja in der garage kommen aktuell fünf mal zweieinhalb quadrat an ich würde sowas trotzdem nicht selber bauen also es wäre mir viel zu aufwendig und ich hätte schiss auf meinem dach hier oben rumzutun
die gesamte garage dran da hängt noch eine man kann sagen auf das dach kommt man ohne gerüst gar nicht richtig drauf also man kann wasch also könnte ich weiß gar nicht man könnte wahrscheinlich vom dachboden
die leiter hoch irgendwie und dann da wahrscheinlich irgendwie raus
ich hab ich hab ein fenster allerdings ist das fencer nicht am dach sondern daneben ne ne also ich hab ich hab kein fenster was wirklich so das dach am dach aufklappt ne also ich müsste dann wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich könnte ich bei mir auf den dachboden
dort die treppe hoch und dann dort irgendwie raus wenn man von innen was wegnimmt oder so weil kein schimmer
16 ampere ce-dose dran das ganze ist direkt verbunden in der kleinen relativ kleinen dose das werden wir alles rückbauen bis zu dem kabel was in die garage kommt werden dann einen kleinen verteilerkasten setzen und da rein kommen verschiedene sicherungen eine ls plus fi-sicherung
und zwei dreimal 16 ampere automaten und dann kommt die ce-dose das das gute vera elektriker setter am start wieder auf eine sicherung und die photovoltaik anlage kommt mit auf eine dreimal 16 ampere kombi sicherung
also wer sich jetzt nicht unbedingt zutraut selbst sicherungskästen zu setzen sollte diesen teil natürlich der installationsfirma überlassen die schiebt den auftrag wenn man glück hat ja trotzdem kurzfristig dazwischen solange zumindest keine arbeit
ja also ich musste sieben ungelungen sieben elektrikgläden anrufen bei mir dass ich in nächster zeit mein ladegerät fürs elektroauto bekommen hab und da musste man auch nicht viel machen
auf dem dach selbst gemacht werden müssen was ich jetzt aber noch nicht ganz verstanden habe wie lange hat denn jetzt insgesamt die installation der solaranlage gedauert wir haben vier tage gebraucht am ersten tag sind wir erst mal hier angekommen nachmittags haben wir das gerüst aufgebaut an der garage und haben dann losgelegt mit der ersten von vier reinen dachhaken die wir an dem ersten abend noch
da hast du was zu tun abgeschlossen haben ja zweiter tag waren die anderen dachhaken das hat ein bisschen mehr als mittag gedauert da haben wir noch die schienen da hast du wirklich was zu tun der module hatten wir auch schon am zweiten tag ja am dritten tag haben wir die module eingedeckt
ja der platz der platz ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht der beste aber ich glaube es ging hauptsächlich um den versuch ob man das selbst hinkriegt was hast du für ein auto ich habe 4 500 e den zweiten wechselrichter gesetzt und am abend noch damit begonnen die elektrik vorzubereiten auf dem dachboden der garage das kabel nach unten geführt um dann alles bereit zu haben für den vierten tag genau dann haben wir nicht ganzen tag gebraucht aber ja schon einige stunden dann in der garage die elektrik gemacht der testbetrieb ist abgeschlossen die anlage war
mal kurz am netz ist jetzt wieder aus und wartet auf die freigabe durch die netzbetreiber aber wir sind soweit zuversichtlich wo ist das problem solange sie es ordentlich machen
also ich würde es trotzdem ich bin ganz ehrlich ich hätte ich hätte keine ambition man davon abgesehen ich könnte es bei uns auch gar nicht da müsste ich wirklich auf ich weiß nicht wie hoch das ist aber es ist deutlich höher viel schlechter zugänglich ich denke auch dass wahrscheinlich wenn das jemand professionell machen würde würde
der würden die wahrscheinlich gerüst hinstellen oder so das ist also bei mir hier was aufs dach zu machen wird erstens abfakt teuer uns ich glaube nicht dass ich so wahnsinnig lohnt wenn man sich die kosten anguckt plus das was man vielleicht dadurch sparen würde also rein fürs geld sparen glaube ich macht es bei mir keinen sinn die anlage lief und hat schon die erste energie geliefert also ich bin ziemlich beeindruckt muss ich sagen also das hätte ich so nicht hinbekommen ich habe aber auch nicht so dass heimwerker
gehen ich hätte es auch nicht hinbekommen ich habe auch keinen bock drauf aber vielleicht sind ein paar von euch ja auch so mutig und begabt dieses video soll euch ein bisschen mut machen die energie wende selbst mit anzupacken ja jedenfalls am ende haben die drei für ihre anlage auf der garage insgesamt nicht mal 5000 euro bezahlt und mit dem gesparten strom und den sieben cent einspeise vergütung für die überschüssigen kilowattstunden sollten sie das geld in weniger als fünf jahren locker wieder
drin haben schreibt in die kommentare 5 jahren kann viel passieren da darf auch nichts kaputt gehen
wobei fünf jahre noch eine überschaubare zeit ist das ist durchaus in ordnung da kann man da kann man sich das überlegen also fünf jahre finde ich was überschaubares anderes die dann irgendwie sagen ja nach 15 jahren oder so wer weiß ob die panels überhaupt zu lange halten
anlage selbst zu bauen mich würde vor allem interessieren wenn ihr das vor habt es aber aus irgendeinem grund nicht geht also verwaltungsaufwand zu groß nicht genug erspartes vermieter die sich quer stellen und das problem mit vermietern habe ich nicht
also da hätte ich keinen bock drauf das selbst zu machen also sollte ich mir sollte ich mir was installieren lassen also wenn sie dann lass ich das auf jeden fall machen aber ich glaube auch nicht dass es hier nächster zeit solar auf dem dach geben wird
das sieht aus wie ein fire ship video so ein bisschen
i am done okay was auch immer geht ganz normal weiter er ist überhaupt nicht dann das ist ja wie früher
auf youtube die videos ich höre auf ich löche meinen kanal und irgendwie zwei tage später nächstes video in scope lifestyle alles klar
naja
ja gut
chat haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes
was ist das
ja das kenne ich das habe ich schon gesehen dass das das habe ich schon gesehen
ich glaube in einem fire ship video habe ich das gesehen
da musst du dich wundern wenn ich in irgendeinem online meeting auf einmal einer den ganzen tag anguckt dann hängst du so der guckt weil der guckt dich ja nicht an er guckt ja den ganzen tag in seine kamera das kann eigentlich nicht sein
ist eigentlich ist eigentlich eine coole sache oder
ja ich kann nichts über einen video sehen hi james was ist das notice etwas seltsames über meinem Gesicht meine Augen sind etwas anders über sie sie sehen normal aus, aber sie schauen mich an genau ich mache nie eye contact mit dir, weil du mich nicht gesagt hast, dass du mich nicht an mir schaust ich nicht ich schaue hier an
das ist eigentlich eine coole sache oder es ist ein bisschen zu auffällig man müsste einstellen können dass das ab und zu halt auch mal wegguckt das ist realistischer wir glaubhafter wirkt ja
ansonsten ist es eine coole technik
realer irrsinn was das wander urinal in was zum
dies ist die geschichte eines kleinen urinals es steht schon länger am großen ebertplatz in köln und fristet ein nischen da sein dabei will die stadt mit dem örtchen doch nur helfen und wild pinkeln eine zivilisierte form der erleichterung das ding sieht so aus als würde ich da nicht auf 50 meter rangehen doch vor allem erfährt es ablehnung also man soll dann pinkeln und in der öffentlichkeit stehen
von oben kann man dann filmen ja theoretisch menschen die hier vorbeikommen fühlen sich gestört der enkel auch der riecht das schon verwalten ich muss auch sagen dass auch hier so eine brise das stink hallesfack ja die stadt köln bekommt mich leid erst mal kurz neben dem gweg eine runde pissen gehen vor allem guck mal wie rum das steht da laufen die leute vorbei während er dann da ein ding rein also ich weiß nicht
im kleinen urinal und stellt ihm ein zweites zur seite deutlich prominenter platziert direkt neben dem imbiss diese idee der stadt beste posi alda unsere gäste hauptsächlich die sind aufgestanden und gegangen wenn ein klo nicht vernünftig gereinigt wird beste posi direkt neben dem imbiss vor allem weil dann die leute beim mittagessen
die stadt reagiert der gastronom hatte sich in den heißen monaten aufgrund der geruchsentwicklung trotz höherem lehrungsrhythmus einen anderen standort gewünscht also geht das urinal auf reisen und zwar zunächst einmal über den platz direkt neben das basketballfeld mittendrin statt nur dabei
mütter und kinder haben dann wie wäre es ohne scheiß wie wäre es einfach mit irgendwie so zwei drei dixi kloß oder sowas wenn es denn wirklich da klobrauch an der stelle
männer beim urinieren zu gucken können wenn sie denn da verweilen wollten erneut gibt es beschwerden immer noch will niemand das urinal haben also geht es weiter eine antwort es wird versucht allen aktörinnen ideen und beschwerden gerecht zu werden weil da garantiert innendrauf geht auf dieses klo direkt neben dem u-bahnausgang etwas irritierend
das ist ja dann das wenn die leute von der u-bahn rauskommen als allererstes quasi sehen sie einen beim pissen das ist zum kotzen für eine frau weil wenn sie da dran vorbeigehen und es entledigt sich einer ist es kein anblick wir frauen
naja ich finde es auch nicht sonderlich toll können das auch nicht also muss das urinal noch mal wenn ich da einen zu sehen muss und weiter zum u-bahnausgang geht es noch ein stückchen weiter jetzt müssten doch alle zufrieden sein mit diesem alles können das sieht so abartig aus ich würde ich würde auf fünf ich würde 50 meter abstand halt sicherheitsabstand egal wie es ist nicht
schön und es ist keine gute lösung der druck muss schon sehr hoch sein auch würdelos für menschen die wirklich ein bedürfnis haben ihre notdorf zu verrichten außer der stadt scheint niemand das kleine urinal zu mögen nur weil sie etwas zu öffentlich ist diese öffentliche toilette
schwachsinn ja also ganz ehrlich seriously wenn es so dringend ist da würde ich mir auch irgendeinen baum oder irgendeinen busch suchen ein bisschen ein bisschen versteckt über dahin pinkeln anstatt an dieses teilnehmer der u-bahnstation also das war ja auch
nicht das wollen sie verhindern damit ja funktioniert halt nicht man könnte auch stellt euch mal vor überlegt euch mal imagine es gäbe an bahnhöfen noch close in die man rein könnte und auch reingehen will wenn wenn man mal muss also sprich die in einem
zustand sind dass man sie benutzen kann dann bräuchte man das meiste nehme ich gar nicht aber das geht natürlich nett vielleicht sogar noch ohne meinetwegen meinetwegen darf sogar ein euro kosten christian linter in linden er
interview das kenne ich das kenne ich das schon schon paar wochen alt aber dann sonst noch hier nie oder sowas verdient man als selbstständiger kfz mechaniker purer gearbeitet als kfz meister umgangssprachlich
kfz technik meister umgangssprachlich kfz meister alles klar wenn ihm der laden gehört dann wahrscheinlich ordentlich ansonsten wahrscheinlich nicht so viel weil man hat halt viel verantwortung bestimmt
im besten fall kommt er halt nicht mehr zum bremsen und dann könnte halt personenscharen entstehen als selbstständiger kann man schon irgendwann mehr verdienen als wenn man angestellt ist ich hoffe die haben keine tos musik wieder im hintergrund
hätte gestern fertig gewonnen mit dem emulator pc da ganz fertig ist man nie aber es hat funktioniert alles 28 jahre wir haben sogar wir haben sogar achievements rein mit addon achievements reingepackt
wie emuliert unser zeug ja kfz techniker meister ich bin selbstständig und dem gehört der laden dann dann kommt bestimmt ordentlich was rum wir haben heute viel zu tun wird ein anstrengender tag und aber schaffen wir schon ist nicht nur eine
marke die wir betreuen sondern im prinzip jedes pkw wird von uns repariert wenn man hartnäckig ist und gut dran ein ap monitor auch den fehler das ist aber halt so die hauptsächliche herausforderung
die habe ich die ersten zwei aufträge gleich dass ich an die jungs beziehungsweise an die mitarbeiter verteilen werde moin hallo wie gehts alles gut so jungs wir haben heute relativ macht der chef erstmal ansprache auf gehts
wir fangen mit den zwei aufträgen an also paulo du machst bitte vier neue reifen bei dem jeep und maruf du machst hier eine inspektion mit ölwechsel alles klar frohes schaffen also ich selber mach viel organisatorisches ich bin ja auch im prinzip der kopf der firma morgen in ümme her vom b&o bitteschön die planung die kundeneinplanung die disponiert
ich frage mich immer warum leute diese low profile tastaturen mögen ich gebe zu hat mit dem video inhalt nichts zu tun ich komme mit diesen dinger einfach nicht klar ich mag keine low profile tastaturen mir ist es auch unbegreiflich dass leute damit gut arbeiten können
von den aufträgen die vorbereitung ich hatte auch von logitech jahrelang auf der arbeit ein ich komme damit nicht klar ich mag die null ein ungeplanter kunde
bitteschön ja also es ist nicht kein motoröl ja sondern eher irgendwie was anderes okay gucken wir uns sofort an mich schlecht normalerweise wenn man da anruft sagen sie ja nächste woche könnte man noch irgendwie vielleicht
könnte natürlich was wichtiges sein wenn es jetzt als beispiel bremsigkeit ist dann wird emulation habe ich euch ausprobiert kommt halt nicht mehr zum bremsen und dann könnte halt personenschaden entstehen da sehe schon etwas das kommt hier vom getriebe also der simmering von der antriebswelle das ist im prinzip so eine dichtung können sich vorstellen von der antriebswelle da an der stelle verliert er das getriebe also sie sehen das hier das ist schon richtig
richtig viel da würde ich ihnen raten dass wir die nächsten tage dass wir danach schauen das problem beheben und da würde ich aber nicht raten viel mitzufahren am besten gar nicht weil dann könnte das getriebe im schlimmsten fall kaputt gehen ich mache ihnen soweit im lauf des tages den kosten vornstag fertig dann melde ich mich bei ihnen telefonisch genau dann danke dass sie da waren und dann sprechen wir uns
für den tag noch
haben die dafür irgendwelche speziellen teile oder warum können die nicht einfach gleich da behalten und machen wahrscheinlich weil es zu voll ist oder oder ist das irgendwie müssen die dafür ja gut vielleicht muss man für das für das auto was was spezielles bestellen
vita emulator gibt es ja die anfangszeit da kann ich mich sehr gut daran erinnern da habe ich mir gedacht werden überhaupt kunden kommen werde ich überhaupt jeden tag aber ja dass das da andere vorher dran sind ist ja ok aber mein man könnte ja beispielsweise dort auf den hof stellen wenn der in der nähe wohnt und es dann morgen machen bevor er da hin und zurück fährt jetzt mit kaputtem auto
es lief aber von anfang an schon relativ gut an aber man hat natürlich immer existenzängste weil man hat halt viel verantwortung
250 euro geht doch voll klar 250 euro geht doch voll klar ihr wollt nicht wissen was ich für meinen für meinen kaputten reifen und felge mit schramme bezahlen musste
genau 250 euro ja ok dann sehen wir uns diesen freitag um 8 Uhr ja schönen tag noch
zu erstmal die gute pizza rein tunfisch tunfisch exzellent oder was ist das ja auch ein bisschen aus wie tunfische exzellent pizza tunfisch pogo das kennen wir das paket mal so bitteschön schönen tag noch her
tschüss ist jetzt nicht großartig an nebenverdienst dazu aber ist das noch ein paketshop oder wie das ist natürlich auch für uns werbung irgendwo ist viele wissen
auch zum beispiel nicht dass sie auch hier eine werkstatt haben weil das schon ein bisschen abgelegen auch ist wie geht es ihnen alles gut soweit paketshop da machen wir jetzt die
batterie aber da braucht er einen der sich da tagsüber kümmern das kann er nicht mittagspause 30 minuten machen die leute kommen ja tagsüber ihr paket
oder macht er das dann bitteschön bis gleich warum ich mich selbstständig gemacht habe erstens ich wollte halt ja im gewissen maßen frei sein weil als angestellter ist man
natürlich an den vorgesetzen gebunden und natürlich auch das finanzielle weil selbstständiger kann man da schon irgendwann mehr verdienen als wenn man angestellt ist
letztendlich hast du halt auch mehr risiko das muss ich halt dementsprechend rechnen paulo kannst du mir mal eben kurz helfen hier mal rausheben bitte
hat sich wohl direkt die neue dann nehmen wir die zusammen noch mal ein ich war im sprinterwerk in düsseldorf also da wo die mercedes sprinter gebaut werden da habe
ich auch sehr gut verdient aber da ist dann auch die grenze irgendwann auch festgesetzt bis wohin man auch verdienen kann als selbstständiger sieht das
natürlich anders aus da hat man eigentlich keine grenzen da hängt hängt von seiner eigenen und unternehmerischen fähigkeiten ab trifft es da
glaube ich am besten so wirklich reich werden die wenigsten vielleicht gehen auch einige ich denke mal bei den meisten wird sich so halbwegs ausgehen
hat er was eintritt das zeichnen kunde am besten mal direkt damit er das mal sieht ja du kannst vielleicht die batterie selbst wechsel ich würde meine
batterie auch nicht selbst wechseln gut beim elektroauto jetzt schon mal gar nicht beim elektroauto ist es in batterie wechseln der als halber auto weg jetzt gerade festgestellt dass da wo die
batterie drin sitzt ja wasser eintritt ist und das ist natürlich gar nicht gut im innenraum wir haben die alte batterie rausgehoben wenn sie hier in das fach reingucken wo die batterie
drin sitzt sehen sie dass der wasser eintritt ist müssen wir schauen also die stoßschangel eventuell runternehmen soweit abdichten das würde ich ihnen eigentlich empfehlen
ja dann machen wir dann zwei termin nur das wollte ich mal gezeigt haben ja dann bin ich gleich bei ihm wieder polo können wir noch mal eben kurz reinheben
kritische musik ja mein jahresumsatz 2021 bei 233.000 euro man hat sehr viel kosten also miete das sagt ja gar nichts wollte gerade sagen also umsatz ist hier nur das alles was reingekommen ist an
kohle weiß ich wie viel mitarbeiter hat was er alles ausgibt das sagt ja sogar erst mal nichts dann kommen natürlich auch materialkosten ein jahresgewinn nach steuer 2021 war
circa 28.000 euro ich hatte jeden monat gute 2300 euro zur verfügung ich muss jetzt irgendwas sagen weil ansonsten weiß ich nicht was weitergeht und ansonsten ist die musik viel zu
garantiert tos ok excellent kein tos mehr es gibt ein problem die anzeige dass die bremse fällig ist da leuchtet die kontrolllöschen auf die ist immer noch an obwohl die bremse jetzt neu ist
da vermute ich dass ja der verschleißsensor da ein problem hat also die klammer die der verschleißsensor der neue der wird der hat da gar nicht reingepasst sozusagen
tauschen wir dann morgen soweit soweit auch noch um dann ist die fehlermeldung dann auch man kann halt nicht alles vorausplanen manchmal kommt leider verkehrt
bis morgen wenn ich also den gesamten tag heute zusammenfassen müsste war das ein erfolgreicher tag es hat eigentlich alles soweit gut geklappt bis auf jetzt die kleinigkeit mit dem
wisst ihr was glaube ich da auch ein problem ist wenn man so hat wenn man generell mein handwerker ist dass viele leute nicht bezahlen ich glaube das ist wirklich problematisch gerade wenn es ein bisschen was größer wenn du beim auto magst jetzt noch halbwegs gehen ja man die bestellen die ganzen teile das wird das danach bezahlt aber generell das einfach leute nicht bezahlen ist glaube ich wirklich ein großes problem was du als handwerker hast
und wenn das einen gewissen anteil übersteigt klar du kannst dann alles mit mannverfahren und sonst was ja und die meisten werden vielleicht dann auch bezahlen aber ich denke wenn das schon relativ geringer prozentzats ist macht das so viel aus dass es nicht mal betreiben kann also je nachdem was es ist also bei einem bei einer autowerkstatt geht es vielleicht noch aber wenn du größere irgendwelche größeren baumaßnahmen machst oder so kann ich
mir das wirklich schwierig stelle ich mir wirklich schwierig vor wenn leute einfach nicht bezahlen oder viel zu spät bezahlen dann wünsche ich schön feiern paulo und wenn sie sich zu viel zeit lassen mit der rechnung da muss sie nicht beschweren aber ich kriege eigentlich mir fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt nix doch doch mir fällt was ein tatsächlich die die bei uns die die dachtreppe also die die nicht die dachtreppe die für
also den dachboden die treppe für den dachboden gebaut haben die haben glaube ich auch zwei drei monate oder so gebraucht bis sie dann endlich mal die rechnung geschickt haben glaube du kannst ich glaube du hast du hast glaube ein halbes jahr darfst du ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher gibt ja irgendwelche so so so verjährungsdinger wie das ist also zwischen zwischen kaufmännern deshalb dass das weiß ich noch
das weiß ich noch so ungefähr ungefähr ich habe ja mal ein bisschen bbl zeug gemacht ich krieg das gar nicht mehr genau zusammen also ich weiß dass es zwischen zwischen kaufleuten andere sachen gelten als zwischen privatpersonen und zum beispiel zum beispiel kannst du auch als kaufmann zwischen kaufmann einem vertrag zustimmen ohne dass du explizit sagst dass du zustimmst
durch das nennt sich dann das nennt sich dann glaube ich konkludierende handlung oder sowas wenn ich das noch richtig im kopf habe manche manche sachen habe ich mir vor meinem bbl scheiß doch noch gemerkt ja auch wenn ich damit nichts mehr auch wenn ich damit nicht nichts mehr zu tun haben will
ist das ein reiter auf der brust ich glaube nicht geht auch als privaten sitze chat ich weiß ihr blickt noch besser durch als ich ja
hallo mama wie gehts alles gut mama beste ich sehe noch kein bedürfnis dass ich meine eigene wohnung habe also solange ich kann will ich natürlich es ist auch sinnvoll ich meine ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie 14 stunden oder so als chef auf der arbeit
zwischen meinen eltern sein es sei denn ich wenn ich heirate oder die frau meines liebens finde klar dann ist das eine andere geschichte ja wollte ich sagen außer schlafen ist er wahrscheinlich nie daheim und kümmert sich ums geschäft also ist doch sehr sinnvoll
wobei ich dann ich habe letztens irgendwo auf twitter oder instagram instagram screenshots gesehen da haben sich medels drüber ausgetauscht welche welche männer man nicht denken darf und relativ weit oben war leute die noch zu hause wohnen
hätte ich meine schwierigkeiten hier schon mal ich meine ich wohne noch zu hause auch wenn das mein zu hause aber ich wohne zu hause und it und it das heißt im prinzip doppelt doppelt gelitten ja can't wait
wir haben verkackt komplett oder oder die medels haben verkackt die wissen ja auch nicht was sie verpassen also man kann das so und so sehen man kann es einfach abgesehen glücklicherweise repräsentiert instagram nicht die reine vibes
es lohnt sich für mich auf jeden fall weil ich durch die arbeit durch die auftragslage von tag zu tag eigentlich meinen zielen meinen träumen näher kommen und ja da gucken was am ende rauskommt steigt auch der umsatz der gewinn und ich denke definitiv für mich lohnt sich das auf jeden fall
also richtig krass viel kommt noch nicht rum aber ich meine er hat ja immerhin die chance durch durch eigene unternehmerische skills das zu verbessern es liegt quasi ganz in seiner hand und das ist ja anscheinend das was er will
also kann durchaus stonks steilberg aufgehen die nächsten jahre über das war es heute von mir danke dass ihr mich begleitet habt hier findet der maschinenbauingenieur und aber wisst ihr was ich interessant finde bei diesen ganzen bei diesen ganzen lohnt sich das videos du hast auf der einen seite leute da hast du den eindruck die schaffen halt auch irgendwie den tag über was und dann hast du manchmal
ähm jobs wo ich mich frage was machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag also für mich das schlimmste beispiel von was machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag war diese unternehmensberaterin oder was das was das gewesen ist ja die hier sales ne moment war die das ich glaube ich glaube die was zum teufel macht die eigentlich auch den was macht die den ganzen tag
das einzige was wir gesehen haben was sie wirklich macht sind irgendwelche excel tabellen und dann die die tabelle mit irgendeinem besprechen das macht die den ganzen tag kann ich mir nicht vorstellen anscheinend ist es so
das ist das ist wahrscheinlich so ein typischer bullshit job den eigentlich keiner braucht diese aber trotzdem gibt leider ist der anteil dieser jobs mittlerweile anteilmäßig finde ich zu hoch
ecoflow delta 2 was soll das überhaupt sein eine große powerbank das sieht aus wie eine große usw oder eine große powerbank ich meine usw ist ja eigentlich so eine art powerbank
hast du noch kontakt zum friseur ab und zu ich hab ich hab gehört der friseur ist jetzt unterwäschemodel
das liegt an den unternehmensprozess ja ja dort hast du die dienstleister sind nicht das problem es ist ja klar der dienstleister der was anbietet kann ja gar nicht die ursache sein sondern derjenige die dienstleister einkauft also es gäbe die dienstleister gar nicht wenn es keine unternehmen geben würde die sie alle haben wollen das ist ja klar
absturz von netflix
3d drucker schreibt meine hausaufgaben
ich glaube nicht dass uns das als ok gucken wir mal bevor ich bevor ich glaube nicht dass uns das als als technik begeisterte leute hier sonderlich beeindruckt aber gucken wir mal
wir haben gestern festgestellt chat gpt ist da auch etwas unbedarft gerade wenn es um linux befehle geht und um was haben wir wo hat es gestern gesagt habe ich keine ah so ob solution das fortnite turnier gewinnen wird ja das wusste sie natürlich auch nicht
ja aber eins muss man sagen diese chat gpt antworten die folgen alle so einem ähnlichen muster und so cool ich die technik an sich finde was mich ein bisschen nervt aktuell ist das reddit und forren und sogar discord teilweise invaded wird von irgendwelchen chat gpt antworten also du kannst quasi in forren gar nicht mehr wirklich darauf vertrauen dass die antworten die dort geschrieben werden
zumindest sagen wir mal wohlwollende leute sind oder stackoverflow sondern dass da vieles bots sind glücklicherweise oder was heißt bots es können auch normale leute sein die einfach chat gpt fragen und die antwort rein pasten das problem bei chat gpt antworten ist halt gerade wenn es um seiten wie stackoverflow und so geht wo leute beispielsweise nach programmier bei programmierproblemen fragen ist halt dass leute
wenn die antwort die leute können zwar auch mist antworten ja aber bei chat gpt lesen sich die antworten halt richtig fife hat und sie sind einfach manchmal auch nur im zweiten abschnitt komplett falsch ich habe gestern ich habe gestern mal gefragt wie ich ssh multiplexing aktiviere da kam raus ich solle mir ssh shuttle installieren
um darüber dann mit team max mein ssh zu multiplexen und sowas war auch irgendwie nicht so ganz richtig als ich gefragt habe wie kann ich in meine ssh config multiplexing aktivieren dann quasi dann war die antwort richtig also manchmal ist da einfach vieles verkehrt und man muss halt sagen chat gpt labert halt ohne ende und die die die dinger die dinger sind immer die dinger sind immer ähnlich die antworten von chat gpt wenn du wenn du chat gpt fragst
welcher streamer hat den besten den besten twitch chat da kommt die chat gpt ahnung dann sowas wie die frage nach dem besten streamer chat ist immer eine subjektive frage
es hängt von vielen faktoren ab zum beispiel der streamer interagiert mit seinem chat wie häufig ist der streamer selbst aktiv und diese frage er erfordert mehrere blablabla also die antworten sind immer ähnlich aufgebaut
da ist co-pilot für direkte fragen nach kommandos tatsächlich besser co-pilot sagt entweder keine ahnung oder meistens was sinnvolles wo chat gpt ganz gut ist ist als ja handbuchersatz wenn man zum beispiel chat gpt fragt
moment machen wir das machen wir doch gerade mal mal gucken mal gucken ob es heute nicht wieder überlastet ist genau also die die die die die die bill die bill können wir auch fragen
die ja habe ich gestern schon ich habe keine ahnung was mit ihnen los ist i have no idea was ist was auch immer also wir können wir können mal fragen chat gpt explain this command rsync-va kann man zum beispiel fragen
und wenn wir glück haben gehts und wenn wir pech haben ist es gerade wieder überlastet dafür ist chat gpt wirklich ganz praktisch man kann natürlich auch explain shell verwenden das geht auch
ok jetzt ist chat gpt gerade wieder abkacken klar auch nochmal ah jetzt hier the command rsync-va is used to synchronize files and directories ok for eyes verbose mode eyes archive mode which preserves permission die antwort ist super
ja die antwort ist super damit kann man wirklich was anfangen ja gestern hattest du erwähnt was wir gestern zu tun welche rapper tut es verhindern für chat gpt und co-pilot das hier moment github einmal ai ask für co-pilot und github chat gpt rapper
ja also einmal das hier das funktioniert ohne dass es was kostet weil das quasi eine browser session emuliert im hintergrund steuert das ein browser fern dementsprechend wenn ihr einen account habt und euch angemeldet habt könnt ihr das kostenlos verwenden so wie ihr es im browser verwenden würdet
das hier ist für das hier ist für github co-pilot es steht nicht co-pilot da aber es ist es ist der gleiche co-pilot engine unten drunter dafür braucht man aber einen api key und das kostet was und das ist gar nicht so billig leute guck mal hier
du bezahlst fast also aktuell bezahlst du nix weil das beta ist und du 18 euro startgut haben 18 dollar startgut haben aber du bezahlst bis zu bis zu aufgerundet 2 cent pro abfrage gar nicht so billig also die api ist eigentlich zu teuer für täglich zu benutzen
überlegt euch mal ich mein 2 cent pro commando wenn die antworten jedes mal wirklich on point und richtig geil wären ok aber ansonsten ist es doch schon ein bisschen ein bisschen teuer wer weiß wie oft du das am tag fragst wenn du dich wenn du dich dran dran gewöhnt hast
also ja also aber das kann ich auf jeden fall empfehlen den chat gpt cli wrapper das kostet nix weil du keine api keys und api benutzung bezahlen musst und du brauchst ein chat gpt login machst du ein browser auflogst dich ein und dann kannst du es verwenden
ja ok auf gehts zu einem thema oder person seiner wahl gedichte anfertigt und sogar auf eigene anweisungen hin ein ganzes programm oder eine app programmieren kann persönlich bin ich davon überzeugt dass das schon die nächsten ein bis zwei jahre die welt komplett verändern wird und eine heftige revolution
ich glaube nicht dass es eine heftige revolution wird wie das internet das internet war ja auch keine revolution in dem in dem sinne das war ja auch über eine eine stetige entwicklung bis jetzt hin über die letzten 40 jahre
im zeitspann von millionen jahren schon und es ist nicht so das chat gpt von heute auf morgen jetzt irgendwie die welt komplett verändert allerdings man sieht sowohl positive als auch negative effekte ich muss es jetzt mal fast zu formulieren wie eine chat gpt antwort
diese ganze bot dieses ganze botting wird natürlich auf neu auf komplett neues level gehoben also was insta wenn ich was ist was stag overflow discord bots reddit bots und sowas angeht das ist komplett neues level mit mit sinnlos antworten die halt direkt aus chat gpt kommen
sicherlich wird auch sehr viel emails spam in zukunft über chat gpt generiert aber ich warte noch auf die kombination chat gpt mit deep l zum zum übersetzen ich meine chat gpt kann auch translate aber das dann kriegst du demnächst auf nigerianisch geschriebene dinger in deutsch übersetzt aus chat gpt und sowas
ja aber das morgen der terminator um die ecke kommt ist eher unwahrscheinlich
warum sollte man das verbieten was ist mit den leuten los mann wer sagt das achso achso ah verstehe an unis und schulen achja ok ja du die sache ist die du wirst es doch kaum verbieten können wie willst du das verbieten
du kannst sagen ha ihr dürft keinen chat gpt nehmen um eure hausaufgaben zu machen ja und wie willst du das wirklich schlüssig aktuell belegen dass es chat gpt ist es gibt tools die das versuchen und theoretisch ja theoretisch kannst du natürlich als lehrer eine
recht hohe wahrscheinlichkeit mit recht hoher wahrscheinlichkeit rausfinden ob das aus chat gpt ist weil du kennst ja den input text du kennst ja deine frage die du gestellt hast so und wenn du die frage dann selbst auf ein paar ai plattformen eingibst und dann antworten generieren lasst da siehst du ja schon ungefähr was da rauskommt
so wirklich richtig hundertprozentig wissen kannst du es nicht allerdings die leute die sind ja nicht dumm und die werden die frage nicht eins zu eins stellen und die werden die antwort wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen bearbeiten und dann ist natürlich die frage ist es denn noch eine ai antwort oder ist es denn ein eigenes werk des des schülers ja also wenn jemand sich mit ai was generieren lässt und das als grundlage nimmt für
eine eigene antwort
dann ist es schwierig zu sagen dass es jetzt ai generiert oder nicht vor allem wirst du es nicht rauskriegen
also ich denke verbieten ist an der realität vorbei zumal es auch die
gefahr birgt dass wenn jemand was schreibt was zu ähnlich ist aber gar nicht aus chat gpt kommt dass
deine lehrer sagt das hast du aus chat gpt und dann will und dann will er vielleicht noch dass du beweisst dass du das nicht aus chat gpt wie willst du das machen du kannst extrem schlecht beweisen dass du was nicht gemacht hast
äh also das ist schlecht oh man
das klingt eher wie ein schlechter hip-hop text
das klingt das klingt einfach nur wie extrem schlechter deutsch rap text
ok es fehlt es fehlt noch ein paar mal das wort bitches und so was in der richtung ok
ja aber ansonsten wer könnte das
zehn jahre alte rapper naja das meiste was es da so gibt hört sich auch so an als haben
das zehnjährige geschrieben nur mit mehr schimpfwort drinne
ja das ist tatsächlich schwierig zu sagen weil du könntest im endeffekt ja auch schon behaupten weil chat gpt trainiert es auf
grundlage quasi bestehen der werke dass das was da rauskommt vielleicht auch schon nicht so ganz der kreativität entsprungen ist also es ist schwierig zu sagen
an welcher stelle das ist also verbieten wird auf jeden fall nicht funktionieren da bin ich mir relativ sicher wie willst du es
verbieten die leute werden es trotzdem werden es trotzdem trotzdem verwenden also das das das wird nicht klappen
so wo sind man hier 3d xdrucker schreibt man aus auf gm ja genau genau sauber github was hörst du für eine musik
also ich höre beim arbeiten so in so 0815 youtube entspannungs kram ja von irgendwelchen chillstep compilations bis
irgendwelches lofi zeug das ist aber nicht musik die ich höre weil ich musik hören will wenn ich
musik höre wenn ich wirklich musik hören will höre ich meistens heavy metal von power metal bis
epic symphony power metal und auch das ein oder andere death metal alle möglichen sachen dabei was
ich überhaupt nicht gerne höre ist tatsächlich hip hop und deutsch rap außer haftbefehl natürlich
haftbefehl wissen wir alle beste ich sag nur goethe straße louis vitor store zahlt die kollektion bar
fick auf sponsor ist das einzige haftbefehl quote was ich kann und was ich wahrscheinlich auch hier können
werde auf dem netz ich habe noch ein bisschen schiss aktuell auf konzerte zu gehen letzte
konzerte habe ich mir corona eingefangen und das war eigentlich gut durchlüftet im frankfurter
stadion ok also gucken wir uns jetzt erstmal an ich glaube wir treiben das ganze auf die
spitze indem wir unseren 3d drucker beibringen mit dem wissen von chat gpt mit einem richtigen
kugelschreiber ganze arbeitsblätter auszufüllen man hat davon abgesehen also 3d drucker schreiben
lassen mit dem stift ist wahrscheinlich also stelle ich mir jetzt persönlich nicht sondern
nicht schwierig vor die ganze movement logik und so ist schon da man müsste jetzt sich jetzt nur
überlegen also software die quasi auf die art die eigene handschrift trainiert gibt es ja auch
da müsste sich jetzt nur überlegen wie man eben das von dieser software die die eigene handschrift
der falls überhaupt falls er das überhaupt macht wie man das translated gescheit bekommt in diesen
diesen wie heißt das wie heißt dieses steuerungs codes für 3d drucker noch mal halt diese
steuerungs code gcode genau wie man das ordentlich in gcode translated und dann ist das ein ding von
wahrscheinlich sich auf github zwei bis drei der richtigen projekte raussuchen es ist denke ich
mal relativ iets sowas zu machen also wahrscheinlich die drei passenden shell befehle ineinander
peipen also ich müsste quasi jetzt mein chat gpt antwort peipen in mein wandel ist in meine
handschrift um peipe es in wandel ist in gcode um und dann ein karl auf mein octopie dann würde
es wahrscheinlich und ich muss natürlich an meinen drucker irgendwie den stift in den stift
rankriegen so unmöglich klingt das gar nicht dieses video wird unterstützt von steuerbord
mehr dazu später wie ein 3d drucker funktioniert wisst ihr ja alle im grunde eine mini heißklebe
pistole die über alle drei achsen angesteuert werden kann und somit schicht auf schicht eine
mini hat ja gar nicht mal so verkehrt zwar kein heißkleber aber an sich ist die habe ich noch
nicht gehört aber die ist die umschreibung ist gar nicht mal so schlecht nur die unterste schicht
und statt kunststoff montieren wir einfach nen stift an den extruder um dem 3d drucker zu sagen
wie er sich dann bewegen soll könnte man problemlos 3d text erstellen und davon nur die unterste
schicht drucken beziehungsweise schreiben lassen das jedes mal zu machen aber fast aufwändiger
als es selbst zu schreiben wir haben also eine laser software zweck entfremdet und bekamen somit
unsere ersten ergebnisse
der schreibt jetzt schon schöner der stift ist halt auch noch nicht fest genug dran komplett geil
einfach als muss schon fest daran sein arbeiten aber es ist jetzt schon komplett geil also er
schreibt halt auch gerade rückwärts aber es ist letztendlich auch egal das f da hat er irgendwie
komplett vergessen bisher also wenn das nicht komplett schöne hausaufgaben sind auch die
ungefähr sind ungefähr so aus wie meine hausaufgaben es ist ja authentisch also einen
gründen warum das so hässlich ist ist halt auch dass sie einfach die buchstaben komisch
verbindet schreibt eine kommentare wer von euch eine handschrift hat die noch schlechter
aussieht als das ist schon ganz geil das problem ist jetzt dass der stifter den kompletten
wackelwalden ist das sagt gerade aus als will er als will er den stift rauchen oder ist das ist
schon ganz geil es sieht aus als zieht er gleich am stift der stifter den kompletten wackelwalden
ist panzer tape naja gut hier ist eine konstruktion wo man den stift einmal reinlegen kann dann
schraubt man das hier fest und dann kann man das hier drauf schrauben problem ist da fehlt
noch ein loch das wundert mich nicht dass leute dafür schon 3d gedruckte sachen gebaut haben
zum selbst 3d drucken um eine stifthalterung an seinen extruder zu bauen und drückt das
teil einmal drüber und da bräuchert sein ha es ist voll geil ja da ist das eine schöne
schrift es ist noch englisch einfach aber es kommt geil und jetzt schreibt er gleich
auf die platte ja gut snooker eigentlich das habe ich in der grundschule geschrieben also
so hätten meine eltern gewollt dass ich eine grundschule schreibt ich habe dann eher so
geschrieben ja ist ja gut print oder hier mal eine andere schrift hat einfach fuchs
was sie ganz gestohlen es ist schon ich weiß warum soll es nicht funktionieren
kommen wir zum spaßigen teil also eigentlich dem nicht ganz so spaßigen teil den hausaufgaben
ich habe hier wie gesagt echte hausaufgaben aus der zweiten der vierten der achten unter
zehnten klasse und wir werden es nacheinander probieren ob die kai das so beantworten kann
und ob der 3d drucker eine echt glaubwürde hausaufgabe damit abliefern könnte viel interessanter
wäre es ob wie du dem 3d drucker beibringen willst an welche stelle er das auf das arbeitsplatz
schreiben muss wenn ich manuell also man kann natürlich das platt manuell justieren fangen
mal mit der zweiten klasse das ist von einer guten freundin der schlotte und zwar ist die
aufgabe hier schreibe die folgenden zehn nomen mit bestimmten artikel da hört schon fängt
schon an ich habe schon gar keine ahnung mehr obwohl das zweite klasse ist ich hätte schon
gar keine ahnung was nomen überhaupt sind wer weiß das chat chat was ist ein nomen auf geht's
chat war chat warum wisst ihr das nicht so nomen wikipedia das ist ein nomen als oberbegriff
der deklinierbaren wortarten jetzt sollte alles klar sein oder
der lateinische wort das lateinische wort hatte in der grammatik anfangs nur die bedeutung von
eignamen als hauptkriterium für die allgemeine wort artnomen etablierte sich dann wortarten
die einen casus tragen können ok ich bin jetzt noch verwirrter als vorher eignamen
ergibt am ehesten noch sinn ok guck mal mal mal mal mal mal chat gpt fragen ob chat was ist ein
nomen ich habe lehrzeichen gemacht ok eine art von substantiv im deutschen fuchs hauseimer
und so weiter beispiel der onkel und ein onkel verstehe die frage jetzt einfach 1 zu 1 so eine
kai der onkel ein onkel der tisch ein tisch der fuchs ein fuchs das haus ein haus der eimer ein
eimer der hund ein hund das fenster ein fenster ich glaube das ist überhaupt gar kein stress
das kritiker ich schnapp mir jetzt mal ein blatt was haltet von ift ja ganz ganz nice leider ein
bisschen zu langsam um da also die haben ja glaube ich ein zustell kann bis zu fünf minuten dauern
meistens geht es halbwegs schnell aber chat also ne nicht chat gpt ist mir ein bisschen zu langsam
zum beispiel für ich drücke auf den knob wo meine tür soll aufgehen und so was ansonsten ist es von
der idee her ganz nice ich habe es aber noch nie großartig verwendet müssen ja sogar mir auch
geschrieben werden schert voll das sind vorher nö verwende ich nicht ziemlich nice weil er
wartet jetzt gerade also das einzige was ich schere ist manchmal ein komplettes laufwerk aber
ehrlich gesagt track und tropf ich lieber in die vm und aus der vm raus wo er den ersten punkt
machen wird und dadurch habe ich noch gelegenheit aber man muss manuell platzieren das platz zu machen
mein gott er legt schon los jetzt nicht absicht aber es läuft jetzt schreibt er selber ich
finde das so geil dass es macht überhaupt keinen sinn die handschrift ist auch richtig schön ich
habe extra in der druckschrift genommen weil klar in der grundschule schreibt man druckschrift
nicht so schön logisch und vor allem und vor allem schreibt man deutlich schneller mit der hand
er zieht einmal jeden buchstaben durch perfekt eins nach dem anderen der tisch ein tisch der fuchs
ein fuchs macht er jetzt gleich richtiger fuchs aber es ist schon eine äußerst schöne schrift
aber aber man ist vor der hand wahrscheinlich schneller ok vielleicht in der zweiten klasse
nicht wobei doch selbst in der 2. klasse bist du schneller und da sind wir fertig ja mega das
nenne ich noch mal aus aufgaben kann man so abgeben würde ich sagen also das wird er kein lehrer abkaufen
wahrscheinlich dass du das gemacht hast und das ist ein echtes arbeitsblatt richtig nice
schöner muffin hier schöner haren richtig süß ein ausflug mit der klasse er backt mit seiner
mama für alle kinder muffins er plant für jedes kind zwei muffins ein oder ein textaufgaben
25 kinder jetzt vorbei fragen kannst du mithilfe des textes beantworten kreuzer an wie viele
muffins backt tommy insgesamt kann man beantworten mit wem backt tommy die muffins kann man auch
beantworten welche muffins backt tommy kann man natürlich nicht beantworten wie viele kinder
sind in tommys klasse kann man auch beantworten wohin macht tommys klasse den ausflug das kann
man nicht beantworten also ihr seht in welche richtung die aufgabe geht an welche tabelle passt
kreuzer an kindermuffins das sind quasi einfach verhältnisse die zueinander stimmig sein müssen
fast fast fast wie die iak abschlussprüfung ich copy paste jetzt das komplette arbeitsblatt
hat einmal mal hier rein und dann schreibe ich dir mal noch dazu wie das läuft das heißt
er soll mir halt einfach hier eine kreuzer einsetzen das ist logisch damit er das einmal
versteht wie er mir den antwort geben kann dann mache ich enter zack das ist das mal
bisschen was mit bearbeiten ja also das dauert erstmal eine weile das stimmt das ist richtig
das ist auch richtig das ist auch richtig dass man das nicht ankreuzt das kann man auch wissen
ja man kann nicht wissen wohin der ausflug geht ja also alles richtig welche tabelle passt die
erste tabelle sagt er passt die zweite tabelle sagt er passt nicht stimmt auch dann zweite frage
da geht es nämlich um den max der am bauernhof arbeitet die aufgabe hier bei max auf dem bauernhof
leben hühner hat insgesamt 25 hühner die hennen brüten jedes wohnen kann 15 eier mit den federn
warm halten heute muss max seine hühner alleine füttern welche fragen kann man damit beantworten
und die beiden die man antworten kann heute stimmt das wie viele hühner leben bei max auf dem
hof ja welche tiere leben noch auf dem hof weiß man nicht wie viele eier kann ein hund warm halten
weiß man auch wann muss max morgen aufstehen weiß man nicht man weiß nicht wie viele eier
ein hund liegt und man weiß auch nicht wie viele hühner braun oder weiß sind perfekt welche
tabelle passt kreuzer an da da auch die richtige tabelle angekreuzt das heißt vierte klasse
bestätigt die kaiets richtig geil multiple choice print und let's go wer das positioniert ja
wollte ich mir voll grad sagen weil das das ist tatsächlich das was ich mir mit abstand am
schwierigsten vorgestellt hätte wie erkennst du oder wie platzierst du das platt so dass du es
nicht von hand platzieren muss aber das macht er nicht weil ich auch verstehen kann das ist
tatsächlich die mit abstand schwierigste sache an diesem ganzen ding da müsstest du nämlich
irgendwie die position erkennen also müsstest das eben mit kamera ausrichten dann irgendwie
offset machen oder drucke anfangen soll gar keinen stress für den kreuz einfach an zack zack alle
richtigen antworten komplett ja und wie hat er wie hat er das jetzt wie hat er jetzt das umgewandelt
in gcode außer von hand aus irgendwie von hand in einem 3d das doch der eigentliche das doch der
eigentliche knackpunkt also wie kommt das von chat gpt wie wird das in g code umgewandelt das
ist nämlich auch die abstand über chat gpt kennt nicht die abstände zwischen den zeilen und so was
das muss man dann alles von hand in einem 3d programm machen oder wie ja dank das ist ja das
eigentlich interessante da dran haben fährt rüber und fertig drei sekunden hausaufgabe einfach
fertig kommen wir zur achten klasse ich habe hier auch wieder ein echtes arbeitsblatt zweiseitig
diesmal von meiner schwester ja also wenn er die faule laser gravierung software ja das ist schön
und gut aber das muss ja irgendwie in die in die laser gravierung software reinbekommen werken
unterricht habt und man sieht auch direkt das hier ok ok das probieren schreibe schreibe die
antwort in g code schreibt man das mit minus da war keine kammer ok das kann es nicht
ich glaube nicht dass es irgendwie sinn ergibt was da gerade rauskommt
jetzt müsste man wirklich mal gucken was eigentlich dieser g code macht online g code viewer wie
selekte ich so ja online g code viewer das da oder hier das funktioniert nicht
hat jemand kennt jemand da was gutes ich habe keinen plan was ist das denn
du hast die hälfte nicht mit kopiert doch ich habe doch alles kopiert ich habe alles
habe alles kopiert hier guckt das da habe ich nicht web g code ok ok
das war weg machen
habe ich was vergessen fack
da ist ja noch mehr da ist ja noch mehr drinne shit jetzt habe ich alles oder ok zack
f50 fehlt
ja nicht so wirklich
das funktioniert nicht so
das funktioniert nicht so wirklich was chat gibt ihr da gemacht hat da irgendwie so ein strich
denn er sollte die antwort in g code schreiben das ergibt das ergibt keinen sinn
zwei zwei linien
ja also das das klappt so nicht
klasse der ernst des lebens beginnt weil hier einfach kein cooler muffin mehr ist
man einfach nur noch ja das arbeitsblatt eins zu eins copy paste jetzt hier rein zack ich habe
ihm vorher gesagt wie das mit der tabelle funktioniert weil tabelle per text das ist
keine echte tabelle aber er versteht das was würde zur herstellung von kunststoffen die
entwicklung von synthetischen materialien und chemischen prozessen führte zur erfindung von
kunststoffen zweitens am beginn der kunststoffentwicklung stand die umwandlung von naturstoffen mit hilfe von
zusatzstoffen und halbsynthetischen kunststoffen ergänze dazu die nachfolgende tabelle darauf bin
jetzt richtig gespannt denn ich kenne die ganzen lösungen noch gar nicht ich erfahre die jetzt
erst hier drauf geschrieben werden da ich präsentiert das blatt und es jetzt geschrieben diesmal
übrigens in schreibschrift weil keine grundschuld jetzt muss ich sagen das ist die falsche art ich
kann ihm nix sagen weil ich keine nicht so einfach dialog machen kann damit irgendwann wird einem
schreibschrift verbracht klar ich persönlich schreibe mittlerweile auch der druck schrift weil
schreibschrift komplett schwachsinn ist aber trotzdem geil dass er einfach alle möglichen
schriftarten beherrscht und da das jetzt wirklich mal eine weile dauert exquisite musikia
perfekt wie gewohnt naja bis auf die eine stelle ich meine ja also auch der drei
drüber machten fehler und ich mein besser ein punkt abzug an die hause kam selber zu schreiben
würde ich mal meinen was steht drin kunsthorn wird aus kasin und formaldehyd gemacht genau dann
zelluloid wird aus zellulose und kupfer gemacht genau erkläre den begriff synthetische stoffe mit
eigenen worten recherchiere dazu auch im internet kann die kai nicht aber trotzdem hat es wahrscheinlich
gewusst synthetische stoffe sind stoffe die durch menschliche technologien und chemie
hergestellt werden anstatt ausnatürlichen ressourcen das ist eine fangfrage leute das
ist eine fangfrage je nach lehrer wisst ihr was passiert recherchiere auch im internet dann das
machen die leute und dann kommt der lehrer und sagt wikipedia gilt nicht als antwort oder irgendwie
sowas das ist so eine fangfrage der will wissen der will der will die leute direkt flamen dafür
dass sie was von wikipedia nehmen es gibt ja immer noch lehrer die sagen wikipedia ist der teufel
so nach dem motto technologien und chemie hergestellt werden anstatt ausnatürlichen
ressourcen mein schwester war so nett und hat mir eine lösungsvorschlag mitgeschickt darunter
versteht man künstlich hergestellte stoffe also kunststoffe ich würde sagen da kann man
den punkt geben dann nummer vier wie heißt der erste voll synthetische kunststoff der
hergestellt wurde bakelite ist auch richtig und dann fehlt noch die zweite seite die müssen
ich auch noch machen so und er schreibt wenn du quelle wenn du quelle wikipedia sagst wird
der der lehrer dann eins reinwürgen je nachdem wie er drauf ist ja wo haben sie das dann her
wiki wikipedia wikipedia als quelle
also das war jetzt auf jeden fall mal ein text den ich nicht schreiben wollen würde und hier
diesmal auch perfekt in den zeilen richtig gut geworden ok also die meisten kunststoffe sind
heute nackt voll synthetisch nennen die drei ausgangsstoffe voll synthetische kunststoffe
kohlen wasserstoffe erdöl und ergas die richtige lösung wäre jeder stoff ist aus natürlichen
ressourcen hergestellt naja du kannst ja theoretisch auch elemente herstellen die es natürlich nicht
gibt wir haben meistens relativ kurze haltbarkeit aber ich weiß was du sagen willst du würde
natürlich recht geben so im prinzip aber rein theoretisch nicht du kannst du kannst
zum beispiel elemente herstellen die die ist die natürlich nicht vorkommen weil es eben keine
stabilen atome formen zum beispiel gibt es da was gibt es kalifornium oder sowas gibt es
glaube ich heißt das so kalifornium kalifornium 252 ist ein künstlich erzeugtes chemisches element
mit dem bla bla bla bla das problem ist dass diese dinger meistens nur sehr kurz halten
so ergas und kohle ich würde sagen das passt was ja da im stadium das gibt es tatsächlich
unter biokunststoffen biokunststoffe sind kunststoffe die aus natürlichen biologisch
abbaubaren ressourcen wie pflanzenfasern der mikroorganismen hergestellt haben den vorteil
dass sie biologisch abbaubar sind und somit die umweltbelastung durch plastikmüll reduzieren ich
finde das geil mich hat überzeugt meiner mann nach steht einem vorrücken in die nächste klasse nicht
zum weg die neunte klasse wird direkt übersprungen es geht jetzt in die zehnte klasse und das
interessante ist hier auch wo in der vierten klasse noch so richtig schöne muffins abgebildet
waren in der achten hat man dann so ein normales als bat in der zehnten klasse kriegste auch noch
eben langweiligen text das ist aber praktisch für uns den können wir mit copy pasten die
kommen tatsächlich von schlottes bruder also auch danke an den und let's go ist ja gut über
dreimal die musik ist ja das ist ein brett das ist eine riesen seite hinten und vorne bedruckt also
wirklich fehlt extrem viel text auch mega geil geschrieben hier nirgends in der zeile
verrutscht jetzt wirklich alles perfekt logisch ist ja auch ein computer und ich fange jetzt
einmal an inhaltlich die aufgabe erkläre die begriffe gleichschaltung und selbstgleichschaltung
und ich lese mal vor gleichschaltung bezieht sich auf die anpassung oder angleichung an ein
bestimmtes politisches oder ideologisches system oft durch den einsatz von gewalt oder durch druck
von regierungen oder machteliten selbstgleichschaltung hingegen bezieht sich auf den prozess bei den
individuen oder gruppen von sich aus ihre ansichten überzeugungen oder verhältnismweisen
anders herrschen system anpassen ohne quasi twitter dass dazu gewalt oder druck ausgeben
werden muss ich finde extrem beängstigend dass der k.i. sowas kann vor allem die hat das nicht
einfach so gegoogelt oder so sondern die versteht das direkt richtig krass also extrem heftig wir
sagen die hausaufgaben sind ordentlich gemeistert es ist auch gerade überall in deutschland mega
der skandal weil alle möglichen studenten deshalb nutzen für ihre prüfungen ich könnte irgendwie
vorstellen dass sie jetzt ganz viele studenten und schüler irgendwie ein 3d drucker kaufen in
der schule muss ich mich früher oft mit papierkram rumschlagen aber offensichtlich dass das also die
interessanteste frage wie er das in gcode umwandelt ja beziehungsweise wie er es in sein 3d dings
programm reinkriegt okay weil es nicht so spannend
und dass die switch ist halt an und weiter
geräte sollen benutzen eigentlich überleben ich gehe jetzt was essen nach bürnen in ja naja
haben sie damals auch immer bei plasma fernsehen und uns fernseher und alten röhrenmonitoren immer
panikgeschwommen oder bürnen in den meisten ist überhaupt nichts passiert großartig
ich habe probleme meine tas motor geflashtes steckt aus an mein unify wlan anzubinden
idee warum da please check credentials diese stimme 100 prozentig was hast du bei dem unify
eingestellt für wlan standards was da unterstützt wird kann durchaus sein dass deine tas motor
steckdosen das nicht alles können und du wpa 2 kompatibilität wieder oder zusätzlich ja genau
oder na gut bei 5 gigahertz wird er gar nicht sagen credentials falsch oder da kann wir das
wlan erst mal gar nicht finden wpa 1 und 2 das sollte eigentlich kein problem machen
dann habe ich keine ahnung
eine ahnung er würde aber immer nicht sagen password falsch du könntest mal in das log von
deinem unify gucken falls das so was hat ob der überhaupt erkennt dass ein client versucht sich
zu verbinden und das ablehnt das wäre nämlich auch schon mal was weil vielleicht ist die
fehlermeldung please check credentials eine fehlermeldung die immer kommt egal was es
für probleme gibt das muss gar nichts mit credentials zu tun haben vielleicht ja auch
das problem dass das wähler nicht richtig gefunden wird was auch immer muss man mal
gucken kann man so jetzt kann man so jetzt nicht sagen leute wir fragen wir fragen chat gpt noch
mal schnell was zwar hallo hallo darf ich da please mach was soll ich heute für ein video
offen anders muss man anders fragen zu welchem thema soll ich heute ein video aufnehmen es
hängt davon dass ist die typische die typische chat gpt antwort die ich erwartet habe das ist
immer so super verträglich und so alles formuliert super diplomatisch wenn sie sich okay einmal
aktuelles ergebnis oder ein interessantes thema in ihrer branche sprechen sie können
auch eine andere ein tutorial ja gut das ist mir klar ja ja okay wir lassen uns mal okay wir
lassen uns mal lassen wir lassen uns mal kurz ein clickbait ein click click click bait click
bei titel generieren generiere ich weiß ich genere ein clickbait titel zum thema emulator
mini pc oder so okay das mag er nicht oder oder ist oder ist wieder überlastet entdecke
die unglaubliche leistung des neuen emulator mini pcs du wirst es nicht glauben okay schon
mal gar nicht gar nicht schlecht gar nicht schlecht machen wir mal generiere fünf clickbait
titel zum thema kann man können wir das thema kümmer das thema besta was was wie was würde
ich denn wie würde ich das dann nehmen wenn ich dann besta diese kleine kiste verändert
dein wohnzimmer hey das ist ein super titel den speichere ich mir mal entdecke den ultimativen
mini pc emulator der perfekte begleitet für deine arbeit an spielvergabt dieser mini mit
dein leben mit dein leben du wirst es nicht glauben lass dich vom leisen also der bett
der beste youtube titel der beste youtube titel ist wahrscheinlich ist wahrscheinlich das
ist schon so ausgelutscht mittlerweile diese formulierung gibt es ja tausendfach das ist
ja auch schon langweilig dieser mini pc emulator wird ein leben verändern du wirst es nicht
glauben für man in den alten computer nice okay noch mal noch mal fünf stück noch mal
fünf stück nächsten die nächsten fünf noch mal der beste auf den markt der beste emulator
für mich spiel aber in stream in einem hole das beste aus deine mini peters der ultimative
emulator im test
aber diese kleine kiste verändert dein wohnzimmer finde ich ein super titel
moment machen noch mal was anderes generell 10 klick bei titel für youtube für youtube
titel müsste ein bisschen kürzer 10 emulator im vergleich
ja ja nicht nicht so wirklich oder nicht so wirklich
wie könnte man das thema könnte man das thema besser beschreiben beste mini pc für ja
machen wirs mal so probieren wirs mal so
erlebe die zukunft des gamings der mini pc der alle emulationsträume wahr macht das
ist legit nicht schlecht das ist nicht schlecht ok bester mini pc für retro oder für für
ähm ja retro games emulation aber der hier ist gar nicht der ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
das das ultimative emulation das ist ohne scheiß so so mies ist das gar nicht das ist
das geht tatsächlich das ist nicht natürlich nicht alles mini pc revolution entdecke den
ultimativen pc für retro gaming emulation der beste mini pc war in deiner lieblings
retro spiele retro der beste mini peter das die vergangenheit wieder aufleben der beste
mini pc retros spiele wie nie zuvor der ultimative mini pc für das ist das ist auch gut das
ist ohne scheiß das ist gar nicht mal so übel gar nicht so schlecht also muss ich sagen ich
glaube ich lasse mir demnächst noch ein paar titel von chat gpt ich meine ich bin unkreativ
as fuck was titel angeht also kann ich mir gerne mal das chat gpt holen so leute ich
gehe jetzt futtern wir sehen uns bis denn macht's gut zu